Hey everybody.
Welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is big wave surfer, Laird Hamilton.
This is an absolutely unbelievable conversation
and I think you guys are gonna really dig it.
So, without further ado, after hitting that subscribe button
please enjoy my conversation with the great Laird Hamilton.
Let's do it.
Laird Hamilton in the house.
Thanks man, appreciate you coming out to do this.
On your mark get set go.
Yeah, let's do it.
It's close, it was close.
We've been going back and forth.
This may be one of the longest your schedule,
my schedule scheduling.
I know.
I know it's been a minute.
We were supposed to do this last week, then a swell emerged
and God forbid, I'm gonna get in between you in a wave.
Not that I could, but that wasn't happening (Laird laughs).
So here we are.
I suppose it's flat out today.
Yeah, well somewhere it's not.
Right somewhere.
But that's the story
of my life.
Yeah, that's where
your dream stage fix you, right?
That's where I hit I almost.
Over
Still checking the distance.
(laughing) Over where there might be as well.
Well, I don't know if you have any recollection
of this at all.
I'd be surprised if you did,
but I don't know if you remember,
but back in about it was late 2012
my family and I were living at common ground
in the yurts behind the restaurant there
and I was doing some stuff with Chris J at the time
and you and your family would come and eat at the restaurant
pretty much every day eating Rodman's amazing food.
That places no longer, right?
Yeah, that was one of the saddest thing I've ever seen.
People work their whole lives to make
a successful restaurant.
You don't ever,
I know.
When you get one, you never,
you're never supposed to stop it (laughing).
But Chris was losing
Yeah, yeah.
like 50 grand a month or something like that
on that restaurant.
Yeah, yeah.
And he was doing it just because it was a passion of his
and he wanted to make it available to the community
but he was like hemorrhaging money on it.
Yeah, well, I think hemorrhaging on that project
the restaurant
Yeah.
was actually the one of the, probably the only successful
I don't know,
thing was going
I think he was losing money on the restaurant as well.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
And we had come out, I was trying to help them figure out
something productive to do with the property but you know,
ultimately he couldn't figure out what he wanted
to do with it and he's moved on from then
but that was like a really precious period
in our family's life to like live on that farm
for that period we were there for like almost four months.
And I just remember you guys coming in and that's
where I started this podcast.
And Gabby was like my third guest on the show
or something like that.
But I would see you and like you scared
like I was intimidated by you.
Like I was too afraid to come and talk to you.
I was like, I've actually heard over there, man.
I wanna talk to him.
But like I never did.
And then it took this many years for us to get together
and do the podcast.
So anyway, that's my big war story.
Wow as soon as I looked at you, I knew you I'm,
like my name stuff is the worst in the world
but facial recognition, I think it's probably connected
to survival,
Yeah.
just so you know, the foes and the friends.
But I look
when you're saying the door, I'm like I know that,
I've seen that guy.
I know you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember Gabby talking to my wife, Julie at one point.
And she was like,
"You guys might like Maui"
you know (both laughing) and that's a loaded statement.
I spent a lot of time on the islands (Laird laughs)
on all the islands and not nearly
as much time as you have obviously.
But there's something very powerful in the energy.
You can feel it when you're in Hawaii, for sure.
And more than any other place on the North shore of Kauai.
And that was a challenging period for us
because you know, we wouldn't,
we were new, we were interlopers and we were trying
to like create a little community or a little, you know,
like plant and roots there.
'Cause we weren't sure we were gonna come back to LA
like we were considering staying there.
And it was hard man trying to navigate
like the unwritten rules about how you behave
in that part of the world.
That's true.
Yeah.
Well and each Island is distinctly different.
Every Island is different.
The sides of the islands are different
and and Kuai is, we know, Kauai is the, well we always say,
you know, bright light, dark shadow.
Right.
You know, it has the,
and it's I mean, I don't know if there's a connection
to it, it's the wettest place on earth.
Yeah.
It's, you know, and just,
it's kind of and it's the unconquered kingdom
by command man and so that the great uniter of the, you know
of all the islands couldn't conquer Kauai.
And so Kauai has kind of a, it has a, you know
there's an aspect to it I think that it definitely
makes you kind of introspective.
I think you just go there and you kind of go in
and if you're not ready
Yeah.
for fully in then it's (laughs).
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, there's incredible light
but there's a heavy darkness there.
Absolutely.
And you can feel it.
And I spend more time on the big Island
Yeah.
and a lot of time,
not, you know, in Kailua, but like
Yeah.
in the small towns
and riding my bike all around the Island.
And I think most people's relationship with Hawaii,
is they fly there.
They're at a resort the entire time.
They have a great time.
That's not a Hawaii man.
Yeah.
And like Hawaii
is a very different place.
And you really, you can't fuck around with that energy
because it will bury you.
It will. Yeah.
And we 'cause Gabby and I laugh
'cause she grew up on islands too.
So she has Island sensitivity and Island awareness
and you see people kind of glamorize,
hey, we're gonna move there and live in the paradise
and the whole thing.
And then you just kind of go, okay, well,
if you're coming in with that naivity,
like you're coming in thinking it's just everything's all,
you know, rose petals, you're gonna probably
have a rude awakening.
It's better to go, you know?
And then Gabby says is the best.
And I, listen, I was raised there, I've lived there.
You know? I mean, it was a technicality
that I wasn't born in Hawaii.
I was born in San Francisco, but being in Hawaii
since I was three months old and I always walk like,
I'm a visitor.
Yeah.
You know? And I think it's important
probably to do that everywhere in life.
Like if you always feel like you're just, you're a visitor,
'cause whenever you see people that get too prideful
of, you know, hey I'm a such and such
or I'm from here or something like that.
I think that kind of like, I think that can hold you back
and definitely affect your conduct.
Yeah. I mean, it requires an extra level of humility.
I think,
It does.
I remember I wanted to shoot some video stuff
and I was talking to Joe guy,
you know Joe, right?
Yeah.
And we were planning some stuff and I thought,
well I can just go, I was gonna go to this beach
and do this thing.
And he's like, you can't do it you know.
He's like, if I'm not with you, forget it.
Yeah.
You know, it was like,
you're, you know,
Yeah.
they don't know who you are.
You know and that's
different and new, like (Laird laughs)
it's like, hey man, I'm not trying
Yeah.
to get in anybody's way
Yeah, yeah.
or anything.
And he's like, no, no, no,
Yeah.
you don't understand.
Yeah. Yeah.
(Rich laughs)
Well, Joe and I have been childhood friends.
I know, yeah, I know.
So I know Joel since we were
little kids.
Is he still doing
his thing out there?
He's still doing it.
He does a lot of community stuff.
So he's working in Hanalei and then working
with the community.
Right.
He's trying to, I mean, the community has ongoing things.
I mean, with floods
and hurricanes.
Right.
And then COVID, and I mean, all this stuff is adding.
I would have thought you'd be already out there by now.
Yeah, I normally I would be,
we just have had a lot of work stuff going on
with the girls, especially too.
'Cause my daughters, you know, my middle daughter
is hitting a lot of tennis balls.
And so there's not a great, you know,
in the wettest spot on earth,
you better have a covered tennis court.
Yeah.
If you want, you know,
to be able to put time into that.
And then my youngest daughter is going to school
which in the past was online now it's,
then it wasn't last year.
And now it's back online of course,
because of what's going on with the pandemic.
But so I'm, the girls are kind of holding me back here.
I'm also just finishing a home on the Island.
Oh, well.
That I've been working on
for 20 years.
Oh, wow, that's cool.
So like a lot, like I have sometimes these crazy
like lifelong goals, you know, that they're like,
they come to fruition like 20 and 30 years down the line.
It's not on purpose, but it just seems like
maybe that's just like a relentless pursuit.
Like you have a vision or a dream or see something.
And then you just, and you get, you know,
you get distracted, but you just keep coming back to it.
And eventually,
Baby sitting it over the years (Laird laughing).
Kind of like how I baby sat getting you on the podcast.
So, two, three years ago.
Yeah (laughs).
But you were talking to Gabby so at the end you had the,
Yeah, yeah.
you know, you had,
you had the good line.
But you don't,
that's interesting because you don't strike me
as somebody who is like a goal setter.
You strike me as somebody who's more like intuition based
like you follow your heart, you follow your curiosity,
your creativity.
It's not like, here's my goal and I'm working towards that.
You see more in the moment in general.
But you know maybe I'm using the wrong word,
I'm using following my path,
my intuitions and following my instincts as,
and then identifying something.
I think I've had the fortune to be able to
kind of I have the fortune to be able to sometimes
understand what certain things will mean,
or you know in time like, hey, if you get on this board
and you start paddling and that eventually that's gonna
people are gonna like to do that.
And they're gonna be able to do that all over.
Just, you know, it's part of that,
you know, I think there's an aspect to innovation
that you understand what the mechanism
or what the idea will eventually turn into.
So I, and then it took, so that almost seems goldish
at times.
Yeah but.
It almost gets a little gold like.
But it's rooted in play.
Like you go out
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
and start playing around
Yeah.
with toe surfing
because there's no waves.
It's not like,
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I'm imagining re-inventing surfing.
Yeah, I know don't.
It's just like
one thing leads to another.
That's true.
And then, you know, a year later you're doing things
that you wouldn't have anticipated when you first
just started fucking around with that stuff.
That's true.
But, you know, I think one,
a quote I really like is that they say that,
innovative people are fulfilled by accomplishing things
and that competitive people are fulfilled by beating others.
And I think I'm,
Yeah.
I'm really on the, I really enjoy the, you know,
that fulfillment of, okay, I think I can do this
and then get and then you not I can beat this guy
or I can outdo that guy.
Yeah.
It's more about, you know, accomplishing these tasks.
Which is
It's internal.
Yeah.
It's an internal thing.
Yeah, yeah.
It's not,
you're not measuring, you've never been one to measure
yourself against what anybody else is doing.
Yeah.
It's all just
how it measures up against what you think you're capable of.
Exactly. Yeah.
Right? Yeah.
Or what's possible, like what and then you might not
even be capable of it, but is that possible?
And then you figure out how to become capable of it maybe.
Right.
You know?
Right, right, right (Laird laughing).
Yeah.
Necessity is the mother of invention so (laughing),
Yeah, yeah, it's, you know, what's funny about that.
I watched, I rewatched "Riding Giants" last night.
I've been, I dunno when that movie came out.
It was a while ago but I hadn't seen it in a long time
and I just watched as a refresher of course.
Yeah stay people out there.
Yeah it's amazing.
Yeah.
And what struck me is, you know, you're,
you've been labeled with this moniker of being like
the innovator in surfing, and you certainly are that
but when you watch that movie, you understand
that the history of surfing is innovation.
It's constant innovation, right?
Like from the very beginning, when you track it all the way
back to the first big waves that were surfed
and how they just iterate and iterate and iterate,
like you're just continuing in that tradition, which is,
it makes it weird when you hear, like,
I know there are people that, you know,
are traditionalist in some regard that give you shit
for trying new things,
Yeah.
but this is what
It's always that.
surfing is right?
Yeah.
From the very beginning back to, you know,
with a thousand years ago I didn't realize like
that's when it started.
Or even more, I think it came out in the necessity
to learn how to navigate, you know, going out
into the ocean when there was surf.
And then then through that, like the guy if you could take
your boat and ride the waves in, then that brought me
Right.
a whole understanding of,
but, you know, I grew up in a time when in surfing
that it was all about innovation.
Like that was the focus.
And then it kind of, I think when the competitive aspect
of surfing came in, it kinda stopped innovation
because it forced a certain, you know,
Rules and structure.
Well, yeah,
Yeah.
because you couldn't
take the risk
Right.
to go out and try something that didn't work.
It would, it'd be like, if you're a bike racer
and you're gonna go on a bike race, you're not gonna try
some new prototype bike
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
in a bike race, 'cause it's gonna break.
You're just gonna go with what you know works.
And then I think that kinda in a way, you know,
they talk about in like in computer design
that all the innovations happen when there was a think tank,
when everybody worked together
and they were just throwing ideas.
And then as soon as somebody got competitive
or they got possessive with an idea
and held it and then stopped sharing,
then that's when it kinda,
everything's slowed down for awhile.
And so, you know, when I was a kid,
I just remember everybody that I was around they were,
you know, I mean it was the sixties and people were,
you know, doing all kinds of drugs as well to give their,
maybe to give their imagination more of a boost.
But the truth is they were,
there was a lot of innovation going on and they were doing
weird designs and weird boards and I mean,
if you look back then and you look at the equipment,
you're like some of the stuff
was so bizarre
Yeah.
looking and then it kinda went through this flat period.
But I think for me, I always, that was the, you know,
Brian Keaulana is a great Hawaiian Waterman
and kind of a Hawaiian chief.
And, you know, he always would say, "Hey, don't define me
by my equipment", which I appreciated that
Yeah, yeah.
It's like, it's just a tool
like, hey, which you know, which tool you're gonna use?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's interesting that the flat period lines up
with the verizon of competitive surfing
and competitive surfing is not part of, right.
Like it's never even addressed in riding Jaws.
No, no.
It's like, it's just not
part of that narrative at all.
And you never even dipped your toe in that, right?
When I was little, we played because it was fun.
You know, when you're a little kid, you go down
and it was like, you and your friends showed up
at the little surf contest at the beach and you all went out
and kind of, it was like, and you know, there was no money
(laughing)
Yeah, yeah.
And then money came along and, you know,
and then it was all of a sudden, it was like,
okay everybody got,
Gets weird.
Yeah.
Gets aggressive and that's--
As you know, looking back now, we're in this
we were talking about social media and our kids before,
(chuckles) before this started.
And you know, how addictive all of that is.
But one thing that it has created is the ability
for athletes in all different disciplines
and specialties to kind of craft their own path.
Like when I look back on your career
like you were really the first or one of the first people
who said, I'm not gonna do, I'm gonna be a professional
athlete on my own terms.
And I'm gonna define what those terms are.
I'm not gonna participate in this structure.
I'm gonna do it outside of that
and that was pretty radical at the time.
And you've been successful in that and let the path
for many to follow in your footsteps.
But now, because of these technological tools
you're seeing athletes do that.
Like they can make a name for themselves
and support themselves doing what they love without it being
in that traditional competitive environment.
Well, see, I mean really in all art, I mean, if you look
at all art in a way, I mean, you look at music
you can get exposure.
I mean, that's one of the, I mean, again, bright light
dark shadow, right?
Yeah.
One of the great things about, you know, social media
and just these tools, the block I call it,
is that you can, it's an opportunity to expose your skills
and your talent to the world.
And let them do, you know, if you, the followers will decide
if you have a bunch
Yeah.
of people following and are interested in what you're doing
or saying, or dressing or whatever it is you're doing,
it's I mean, you can make a living from it.
Right.
And which is pretty amazing.
It is cool.
I mean, it's--
It's super cool that people can do that.
It is, it is.
And it's allowing a lot more freedom in art in general,
Yeah.
When I call art,
I just mean self-expression, right?
In a way it's forms of self-expression.
And in my case, it just happens to be in sport.
But in some other cases is in music, it's in cooking,
Right.
It's in fashion,
it's in, you know lifestyle,
Yeah.
it's you just go down the line.
But it had to be hard back in those early days
trying to figure out how you're gonna make that work, right?
When you just try to do everything.
I'm sure you had people in your life who were like,
what are you doing?
Yeah.
Like you got to get a job, right?
Yeah, well, you subsidize it any way you can.
That's why I did, you know, it's like, oh, a modeling job.
Hey, you look good in that thing, take a picture.
Or, hey, you're gonna be, you know, be a in a movie
and you can do stump we're okay.
I'll do that, I mean, it's like,
Right.
you just do what you,
you did whatever you needed to do to subsidize your
Yeah.
I always say, you know,
now I'm in a position where I can subsidize
my excavator work with surfing.
Yes (laughs).
I would subsidize
surfing with excavation.
Yeah.
Like, I'd go dig an excavator so I can go surfing.
So you did whatever you could.
I think one thing that really allowed me
a real opportunity was Oxbow, which was this,
the French company that sponsored me for more than 20 years.
And it was, you know, because I didn't have to, you know,
cut trees, mow yard, dig holes, support cement, hammer nails
all to survive because I had that kind of, that support.
It allowed me a little more freedom
Yeah.
to practice my skills
and to be creative and to work on stuff.
And so that was a fortunate thing, I think without them,
and that support during that stretch of time,
I wouldn't have had quite the luxury
to be able to be as creative as I was.
Right.
So I think that,
that was a unique thing that happened, but you know,
all along the way, you're always, you know,
you just do whatever.
The puzzle pieces,
but you grew up, you know, on the, when you're a kid
on the North shore and you're seeing all those dudes,
Yeah.
you know who
obviously influenced you so profoundly
like that's what they were doing, right?
Yeah.
So you realize like,
oh, I can figure out how to get a bag of rice
or whatever I need to live.
Absolutely.
Oh yeah, they'd do whatever.
Yeah.
Fishing in the summer,
work on the thing in this way, I mean, you did,
they would do, I mean, and it's a little bit like,
it's a little bit Island lifestyle.
Like I, sometimes I get around people and they're like,
well, how do you know how to do that?
Like, how do you have any know how to fix that thing?
And I go, well, I lived at the end of a road
where if you didn't fix it, it was broken.
Right.
There was no, like,
call the guy that fixes those.
There was no, you know, it wasn't so specialized.
Like it is now, like, you just had to kind of, you know
I always love MacGyver, like MacGyver for me is the best.
Just give me the bubblegum and the duct tape
and a little tie wire.
And, you know, and you can just Jerry rig something
and get something that was broken to work.
And I think that that mentality is definitely useful
in, well, not only survival, but in innovation.
Yeah innovating all these,
Yeah.
new iterations
of what surfing is convey.
Yeah, exactly.
That imagination.
That's what Thomas Edison said.
He said, " All you need to be an inventor is an imagination
and a pile of junk."
So I'm like, well, I always had the junk,
He's a good marketer too though.
(both laughing) He knew there's always that.
He had that part dialed.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, there's that too.
That's a piece of it.
I wanna talk about water and your relationship to water
and the ocean, like I'm in certain respects
like a different kind of water, man.
I'm a swimmer.
I grew up swimming, swimming is my passion.
And it started in pools.
And, you know, I've done interesting things in the water.
Like monofin swimming, things like that.
And now it's about ocean swimming.
And then I got into ultra endurance triathlon
and all of that, but I have a very deep
and emotional connection to the experience
of being in water and underwater.
That's overlaps with yours a little bit, I would suppose.
So, I'm interested in how you think about your relationship
to the ocean and, and you know, how you articulate,
like what that means.
First of all, that's my Grandmaster, right?
Like if you said, who's your, you know, people say,
hey, who do you look up to?
Or who do you, you know, who influenced you?
I mean, I'd have to say that the ocean probably has had
the biggest impact on shaping, you know, the way I behave
more than any one person except maybe my mom.
'Cause she birthed me and she had a huge influence
of course, but the ocean, the lessons that you learn
from the ocean, the relationship that you have with it,
it just, it covers so many things.
And I know that, you know, my reverence for the ocean,
just my reverence for its power, its beauty, you know,
it's magnitude.
Like it's just the massiveness of it
and insignificant, it's our space, right?
Like the ocean is our space on earth.
Like if you wanna know what space is like,
you just go to the ocean
Right.
and that'll tell you
what you can go to the edge of the space
or you can go deep into space.
And it's been, it was a great escape for me when I was a kid
to leave kind of the cares of the land behind you
Yeah.
and all the worries
and all the stresses.
When you're underwater,
all of that gets muted, right?
Muted.
And it's just between you and the elements.
Yeah, and maybe just a giant shark
that may be lurking in the distance (both laughing).
Right?
There's always that
in the back of your head, like, hmm, Let me see.
I'm not a big fan
Right.
of swimming out in the middle of the ocean with a mask
that you can't see very well.
But (laughing),
Yeah.
but you know, so I think I, you know, so the relationship
with the animals in the ocean, with the way,
just with how it makes you feel like it
like the therapy of the, it's heels you.
It's like being back in the womb.
It is.
You know?
Yeah and you get healed from it.
Like you can go and be in the water and you know
now we get all these science, you know, science follows
I say science follows instinct, but you know, you get
you have these ideas like, hey, this really like,
I go there and I feel different, everything's different.
Then they get some data in there.
So like, yeah, that's 'cause
Right.
you're getting negative ions
Yeah.
in the thing
and you're grounding, in your preparation
Right.
and all this stuff but.
Andrew Huberman shows up
Yeah.
And validates
what you've been telling yourself for 20 years.
No, it's true.
Yeah.
It's true.
And that's kinda, I mean, that's pretty amazing that
in this time, you know, in the world that we can do that,
that we're getting to do that.
But it seems like your instincts, you know,
your gut instincts and your intuitions and all those things,
those serve you right.
And I think there's a karmic thing.
I mean, obviously the ocean is the most conductive
element on earth.
And so, you know, sound travels through it, waves,
sound waves, but also wave energy, what we ride.
Yeah.
So, you know,
and I know like karmically, you know,
whenever I'm in the ocean and I have some negative thoughts
or some feelings or something
I usually just pay instantaneously.
Right.
It's like I crash,
the wave comes and hits me and I'm like,
Karma comes quick.
Oh yeah, that's right.
I was supposed to, I gotta shed that stuff.
I gotta,
Yeah.
clear my mind.
I know that again,
like a deeper level of humility.
I mean, there's this idea
that you're conquering these waves.
You're not conquering these waves (Laird laughs),
you're trying to,
Yeah.
you're trying to
exist in symbiosis with them, right?
Harmonious, that's always talk about the harmony.
Riding the wave is an act of, you know,
is an act of harmony.
You're trying to be harmonious with it.
You don't conquer waves.
Right.
You have the fortune to ride them for a moment
and be part of them and you know, if everything goes right.
But yeah, you don't, there's no conquering
No, no, no.
the ocean that's,
No, and I, you know, my sense is that it gives you
this deep appreciation for the natural world, right?
It does.
Like, I had
Alex Honnold on here, I've had Kílian Jornet
and like the themes, you know, it's just this like
the majesty of nature is just so profound when you're,
you know, in the midst of trying to do your thing.
Yeah well that being observent.
In harmony with that harsh natural environment
where the stakes are very high.
The observant, you know, being observant I think that's
even today, like I was at not my house.
And there was some Hawks that fly by my house
and just, and they come and you know,
and it's and the more aware you are,
it seems the more connected you become to it.
And all of a sudden it's almost like they come over
and say hi to you.
And you're like, hey, how's it going?
They go (craws) and they turn away.
Yeah.
And I mean,
if you could go yell, okay, the hawk
but did the Hawk?
I mean, you're connecting with the hawk.
The hawk came and but you have to be observant
to even see the hawk.
Then you have to actually put the energy and the thoughts
to the hawk in a way that you, that your,
how you're observing it and what you're,
what it means to you.
And that happens with the dolphins that happens with the
you know, the whale that happens with all the creatures
of creation and ultimately nature.
I mean, nature is just, I mean, it's.
It is creation, right?
So we talk about creation, the great creation,
will nature's creation.
So, you get to observe it.
And I think being aware of it, being aware of the sunrise
and the sunset and the movement and all that stuff
connecting to it allows you a deeper relationship with it.
You just can't, 'cause you can't have this deep relationship
without it, without connect, without having the, you know
the observation and being aware
Yeah.
of all these things
as you become, the more aware you become
the deeper that relationships become.
And then the more it shows itself to you.
Yeah.
It's like people talk
about going on these journeys and reconnecting with nature.
And I'm like, if you're already reconnected,
if you're already connected,
then that's not gonna be so profound.
It's just, it's so many of us have grown so far away
from hey, it's hot.
I'll turn the AC on.
Hey, it's cold turn the chill out.
Hey, it's dark keep the lights on,
hey, you know, it's bright but the shades on
Yeah.
it's like, we're just,
we're insulating ourselves from it.
And, you know, and obviously the ocean is the King
Right.
because it's alive
and moving
Yeah.
And has, I mean, all the things it can do,
just freezing and liquid and steam.
And just to, I mean, we just, it's like the un, you know
the unexpressable element,
Yeah.
It just has too many.
And still so mysterious.
Mysterious.
You know.
But on the hawk example,
(Laird laughing)
I mean I think the hawk example to me
is an illustration of the fact that no matter where you are,
you're still in nature.
Like we have this bifurcated, like idea,
like right now we're not in nature.
Like if we need to go down to point doom to be in nature
but we're in nature right now.
Oh, absolutely.
We are always in nature.
And we always have that opportunity to be more connected
to the environment and the energy
and everything that's going on
if we can be still and observant.
Amen. I think that that's one of the things that
will help everyone will help humanity the most
is if we can continue to re, 'cause we have it right?
We have an ability to really be connected to nature in a way
that we don't, is so profound we don't even fully
understand it, the depth of what we're capable
of and what we, and the depth of that relationship.
'Cause, you know, I always, you know, we are it
and it is us.
I mean, we're so con, you know, if you think you're
not connected to the sun (laughs),
if you think you're not connected,
Yeah.
You know, everything
and you're not, and it's not you and you're not it,
then that's, you know,
Right.
and that's the big separation right now.
And it seems that in the present that we've become
so insulated that that's what's leading
to people being, you know, either depressed
or having physical ailments or whatever it is.
A lot of it is 'cause they're not fulfilling,
I believe they're not fulfilling, you know, this void
which is what nature was fulfilling.
Right.
Like nature was filling
this void in them through just even observation,
Yeah.
even just looking
and connecting that way it's filling this.
And then all of a sudden you have this void
and then you're just putting stuff in it that the body,
you know and the soul and everything can't,
Yeah.
Can't connect to (chuckles).
Not, probably not a lot of, not an epidemic of anxiety
and depression in, you know,
No.
indigenous tribes that are, you know,
dealing with survival and connected fundamentally
to the world in which they live (both laughing).
You know what I mean?
None (laughs).
There would be none.
(laughing) Yeah.
That no allergies either.
But then allergies (laughs)
But then on top of that
to engage in, you know, the high-risk kind of adventures
that, you know, light you up
Yeah.
gives you, you know, it puts you in this contact
with the fragility of life or what death means
that I think enlivens your daily experience, right?
Like how do you think about risk and death?
Well, I mean, first of all I think
that's the most honest way you can live.
The most honest way you can live is to know that dying
is very easy and you can die any minute.
And then how would you conduct yourself?
You know what I mean?
And it's, and I think for me, that's a daily challenge
and a weekly challenge and a monthly challenge
and a yearly challenge is just to always have
that kind of awareness that death is ever present.
And then, and the truth is is that
the truth is that right now death has a name
and it's walking around and people are,
it's affecting people severely because they,
because their relationship with death is so insulated
through just the way life has become that it's,
we're not living honestly,
Right.
like we would
if we were out in nature being threatened constantly
by stuff, then we'd be, our awareness would be
so heightened, but I, you know, I feel that you don't know
what being truly alive is unless without that relationship
to that edge, you know, to knowing where that edge is,
like when you're a kid like, hey where's this place where,
you know, where do you fall off?
It's just a big it's if you take the evolution
of what's dangerous when you're a little kid
and you grow into a mature adult then you go, okay, well,
that's the same relationship.
It's just, everything has become,
the scales have become bigger.
Yeah.
but it's still honest.
It's just so honest.
It's I know for me, it makes me a better person.
If I am, if I go in those situations and in the environments
and around the strength of it,
the strength of vulnerability, right?
Yeah.
The strength of true
vulnerability, and, you know, the highest end
of vulnerability is death, right?
Yeah.
I mean, there's all kinds
of vulnerability like, hey, get your feelings hurt.
And, you know, the tribe might except you,
public speaking, I mean, people are fear
that more than death
Right.
because they're worried about acceptance.
So, but vulnerability, right?
Being vulnerable and how that makes you
and that makes you just feel so alive.
And that's honest, that's it.
Yeah.
What's interesting about that is that it runs so counter
to every message that we see out in the world,
which is all about comfort and luxury, and you know,
fancy bullshit or whatever.
And we're, you know, sort of fed this narrative
that if we wanna be happy, it's all about,
you know getting this stuff or isolating ourselves
removing ourselves from anything threatening
and in truth you're living example of this,
that sense of purpose or that engagement with the world
that gives you that feeling of being alive
only comes through challenging yourself
or immersing yourself in the elements
and pushing the boundaries of what you're capable of.
And it's something that it's not like a one and done
you gotta do it your whole life.
It's a practice.
Anything else.
Like it's a daily practice.
And the truth is that's the irony, right?
The irony of the story is that that all the things
that you think, are what you need are the things
that are gonna are gonna bring you the furthest away
from your goal, which would be to feel alive
and to be healthy
Yeah.
at the end of the day, like what's,
it's connected to health, right?
It's like, you know, the irony is that exposing yourself
to a great threat makes you the healthiest you can be
which is, that's like,
Right.
that's the most confusing thing ever, right?
Yeah.
Like, okay, go do
dangerous stuff and then that'll make you
the healthiest you can be.
You're kind of like, okay, well, that seems like,
it seems like you should be really safe and do things.
And then that'll make you vulnerable to be really sick.
(laughs) You know, it's like that
Right.
it just doesn't,
but that's, it's that simple.
Like, it's really that, I think there's sim,
you know, I always talk about if everybody scared themselves
once a day, that and genuinely scared themselves once a day
it would be good for you.
Like, it would just reset, like everything gets reset
and you're like, okay, all right.
Like and I use an example of, you know,
sometimes you're driving down the road
and you're kind of just, you're feeling a little flat
and all of a sudden something, you know, an animal runs out
or car almost get, something happens
and you get that adrenaline boost.
Right.
And then all of a sudden,
you're just like your vision gets real sharp.
All of a sudden, you're just like,
everything just gets clear.
And you're like, you're aware.
And you're, and your senses are in high alert.
And then you're like and it took that it was just boom,
that quick.
And that living in the state of that kind of awareness
is such a better, it's just a better way of you know,
it's like
Yeah.
it's a better way to live,
Yeah, but it's also
about having a healthy relationship with that too,
Yes, yeah.
because you can,
you know, you can have
Yeah.
an addictive relationship
I have a five friends
to that that will destroy
your relationships.
Yeah.
And, you know, you just become,
you have tunnel vision over
That's right.
what's the next thing that's gonna jerk me up, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm sure you have,
I've got friends like that.
Yeah.
A lot of them work here actually (laughs).
There's a lot of destruction in the wake.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah (laughs).
Right?
Yeah, a lot more going,
Yeah.
A lot of guys I know
that were
I mean is that ever been
like something you've had to like, you know, deal with,
or you seem pretty grounded and level about the whole time?
Yeah, you know, I mean, listen, I think I was
I've been fortunate to be around enough of those guys
and watched, you know, I've seen a lot of good guys,
you know, die (chuckles sadly) because of the,
either the complacency from doing it,
doing stuff and not retaining that respect.
Maybe they got a little comfortable, you know,
it's like they, they drop their guard.
And most of the guys that I know that went down
doing dangerous stuff, it was more about that.
You know, it was just maybe too many times at it
or too much of it and not enough balance
like not enough, you know, it's like, for me I feel like
it's important to get, you know, I guess for me the,
when I look at it, 'cause I'm like you said, not huge,
like obvious goal setter but I have one goal in mind,
which is to live.
To survive.
That's at the top.
Yeah.
That's the thing and I want it
(laughing) That's a good goal to have.
and I'd like to be
Yeah.
and I like to be to be old and gray.
Like I would like to, I see that as like the objective
is to be standing at the end, right?
And so if that's the goal, then that means that you
have to go about things, not like, you know,
burnout hot and go out on fire.
Like, because I think that that and that's I mean,
at a certain point along your course,
you got to make a decision.
You have to make a decision about what, you know,
'cause you can get caught into that, right?
You can get caught
Yeah.
into that and there's something pretty selfish
about that actually.
And so, and because at the end,
I mean, when you die, you don't care but what
about all the people
Right.
that care about you?
Yeah.
And so, in a way you got your people that you love,
your family, your friends these other people that,
so some of it becomes that, some of them becomes like,
hey, you know what?
Do I wanna do that to my kids?
Yeah.
Do I wanna do that
to my wife?
I mean, we don't know the time or the place,
of course, no one does.
And it could be in 10 minutes,
it could be in 10 days could be in 10 years,
could be, you know, we don't know that, right?
So, but the honest way to go about it is,
you know, okay.
You know, we always go any risk taking that we take,
we it's all about, there's a kind of a methodical process
that we go through in that, so that, you know,
the more dangerous it is, the slower you go.
The more preparation you have, the more,
you know there's this certain like formulaic process
that you do to do things
And muting out all
the external noise, right?
Yeah.
So that you can hear your intuition and you know
when it's the right moment.
Well and be good with saying no.
Yeah.
Being good with like,
ah, you know what?
No I just, I don't feel it.
Right.
Like today's off or you're
Like when Alex Honnold's
on the wall, he was gonna
Yeah.
make the ascent.
That was the best
thing ever.
It's not, yeah.
He's like, I'm not doing it today.
I respected that,
Yeah.
particular scene in the film.
All the camera men are up there.
I'm like,
They're ready to go.
That's the exact, that's perfect.
I go that, I respect that.
Not, you know what, go anyway, and then timber.
Right.
Because you sensed it.
But the pressure of all the whole thing, I can appreciate
that because it's knowing how to make the,
that's a big judgment call.
That's.
It's huge.
Yeah.
'Cause those guys
were already all the camera man had scaled up
Their were already
Exactly.
there was a lot of stuff that was already in motion.
So, being able to like completely tune that out
and not have that be part of the calculus
about whether you're gonna do that hard thing or not.
Important.
It takes a lot,
that takes like a you know, a solid, you know, barometer.
Important.
Yeah.
Yeah. And I think that that,
but that's a reflection of the real barometer
that allows you to do the other thing too.
So at the end of the day, it takes a certain, you know
for him to do that, actually be able to do that climb.
You really have to have a certain 'cause people, you know,
I think when people watch things that are, you know,
in, from their perspective, you know, beyond understanding,
they like to put, they like to disclaim it as okay.
That's just a reckless person.
Right.
That person just is,
they're just, you know, they're just reckless.
They don't wanna say, "Hey, no, that's some calculated,
"well, you know, well orchestrated, prepared."
It's the end point on a multi-decade journey
that this person's been on.
Yeah.
You know, and it's easy
to look at you and say, well, Laird you know,
of course, Laird can do that.
'Cause Laird is Laird you know
Yeah.
and certainly you have, you know, some genetic gifts
and you have a certain level of talent but to dismiss
what you're doing is just a well that's because he's Laird,
is to deny like all the work that you've done,
like this dedication that you've shown
over the course of your entire life to get you
to the point where you can drop in on a wave
that nobody's ever surfed before.
Yeah. Well that's, and I think that's the,
I think that's always the part where, you know,
when they talk about people being adrenaline junkies
and all that guy's just an adrenaline junkie,
I think that's a way to let them off the hook.
So they don't have to actually, you know, to do the work
and pursue the thing
Right.
that they might be interested actually in.
But they'll be like,
Oh yeah, no, that's just the way, you know that's the way
that this a disclaimer to let that people off.
It's an easy yeah.
It's an easy way for people to not have to look
in the mirror ( Laird laughs) and evaluate, you know,
Yeah.
where they might have
More potential
because that's scary.
Scary.
And a lot of people don't wanna do that (laughs).
They don't.
And you know?
No.
But at the same time
there is that kind of you know, addiction junkie mentality.
Yeah.
There is a strain of that
in all extreme sports in life.
But, you know, it's certainly part of the kind of historical
record of surfing.
You know, you grew up in a culture of like play hard,
play hard, right?
Yeah.
But you've emerged from that as somebody who I look at
as, you know, part of, I would suspect now the young surfers
look to people like yourselves, it's not about the partying
lifestyle and it's really about how can I optimize
my performance and body, mind
Yeah.
and spirit, right?
Like, you've sort of set the tone
Yeah.
for this next generation
of surfers and you see it like the Smith Brothers
are all about that.
Like, there's a, it's a healthier ecosystem right now.
Well you know, listen I was around a lot of radical stuff
Yeah.
When growing up and you know
I can remember, you know, seeing guys that you looked up
to that were like your heroes, and then you'd see them
on a you know, on a park bench with a paper bag
and, you know, fallen over.
And just how painful that was.
Like as a young guy,
you see, and
'Cause you're like,
you were the guy who you were that I looked up to,
Yeah.
right and now my hero,
You're my hero and there you are in the gutter.
And I saw it more than once.
And I think, you know, I felt like that if I was ever
in that position that I would look at it
like a responsibility.
If I'm fortunate enough that somebody will look up to me.
And except for some reason at all, I don't wanna ever give
them an excuse to justify and including my children,
you know what I mean?
It's like, I was, I used to,
well, I used to but I loved, you know, I love red wine.
I'd go to France.
I had French company, I go go to Bordeaux,
they'd send me cases of the most beautiful pin on walls
in the world, and I'd be like, you know,
this gorgeous stuff.
And I was like, but I liked it maybe a little too much.
So I was like, you know what?
I don't want anything to have quite that kind of power
over me that I could 'cause my mother was a drinker.
And, you know, we have long family, you know,
a relationship with drinking and I'm like, you know what?
I think that's gonna be a problem.
So if my daughters decided that they wanna drink,
it won't be because it was just part
of what we did at our house.
And it was just like, accept that I'm gonna dip.
It's gonna be because they discovered on their own
they do it on their own but it's not gonna be because of me.
So, a little bit, you know, I think a combination
of all those things I've seen seeing guys that,
you know, ruin their lives.
And I seen deaths like bunker spreckels, you know,
overdosing and guys, you know, and then heroes being in,
you know, just hero to zero.
And then you're looking at that guy and you're like,
wow what a bummer that is and what disappointment that is.
And, you know, and at the end of the day, you know,
leading by example, like in a way it's the same thing
as parenting too.
You can say whatever you want,
they're just watching what you're doing.
Right.
So, it's like
at the end of the day and I think that's true with,
you know, if you're in a position of influence, I mean,
and I see it in a lot of major sports.
I see, you know, a lot of influential athletes promoting
you know, stuff that's, you know, poison to people
and, you know, for money but obviously
they probably have enough money.
They really don't need to do it at the end of the day.
It'd be kinda good to have some discretion kind of go
you know what, probably not that stuff
Right.
'cause that stuff
it's not so great.
And then every little kid that looks up to you is thinks
that they can drink that and it's gonna make them like you
or whatever that, so I think there's a lot of things that
you know, and then don't forget just wanting
to have optimum performance like wanting to have (chuckles)
wanting to be able to continue to perform at a certain level
and, you know, be the gray hair.
Yeah.
At the end,
be on the top of the mountain
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
and you're not gonna do that.
You know, being stupid so.
Well, you've always had this growth mindset, right?
Like you're always devoted to like trying to iterate
and innovate and all these things.
And that's, I think harder than it seems or it looks
like most people kind of figure out what their lane is
and then, you know, they become successful in that lane.
And then you get calcified around that.
It becomes harder to be creative.
Yeah.
And to question
your set of beliefs or your approach, you know,
as an athlete, like this is how I optimize my performance.
And then you don't wanna hear about any new ideas
or anything else but you seem like somebody
who's always been really open to learning and experimenting.
You know, I attribute part of that to where I grew up.
So, because I was, you know, I grew up in an environment
where there was a racial thing
against guys that looked like me.
And so I was already, I kind of had, I had that.
I think that was helpful because I had, you know,
I always used to say, you know, people don't like you
for how you're born and why would it bother you
if they don't like how you behave?
And so, at the end of the day, it's like, I think that
being the willingness to be a beginner again and not,
and be okay with people laughing at you
and like you being like, you know,
hey I'm gonna try this thing.
And it's stupid.
And people are like, that's so dumb.
Why do you, you know, I mean, multiple times
through some innovations that we were involved in,
either we had people just naysayers going
Right.
that's lame, you're,
you know, that's not surfing or what you're doing
is not this or so I was used to that.
And then it becomes almost a formula.
And, you know, I talked to my friend Paul the other day
about, you know, how we like the early part of the curve,
you know, that early part of the curve is nice and steep
when you go from, you know, a beginner to like starting
to become proficient at anything,
it's a really fulfilling thing.
And then once you're at this other thing,
you're at a real, you know, you're at a plateau
and you're just scraping for you know, for little tiny,
you know, millimeters.
And, you know, I talk about surfing
and you look at the amount of hours that we have being okay,
will another hour on the 30 or 40 or 50,000 hours
that you have you think that's gonna make you better
or is being more flexible gonna make you better
Yeah.
Or is good being stronger
gonna make you better, you know, these other things
are gonna have a more of an influence
but you gotta be willing to be a beginner.
I think the biggest thing is about being a beginner
and willing to subject yourself to failure
and being okay with that.
I think I've been hurt.
I've had enough injuries.
It helped me with that process where you wonder if you're
ever gonna be able to do the thing you did
and then not being, and then having a, you know
I think there's a, to not be a narcissist
and to not be a, have an ego and all that.
That's impossible.
There's no way you're not gonna have some narcissism
or are some ego aspect to you.
Yeah. I mean, you have to have a bit of an audacious sense
of self to even attempt these things.
And there's a healthy aspect of that.
It's about keeping it in check, right?
And (laughs) making sure that it's not the,
it's not ruling the rooms.
Exactly.
Exactly so, and I mean that's an important piece to it,
but you know, willing to fail,
being okay with failing is important.
And I think, and then what happens
is you do it a couple of times and then you're like,
Oh yeah, I know I'm at this part in that journey.
And then you do it again.
Then it becomes almost a formula right,
there becomes a formulaic aspect to learning, right?
Or creativity.
When you have an idea and you're on a napkin,
then you make a prototype, then you break it and you crash
and you can't do it.
Then you can kind of start to do it.
And then eventually get to a point where it's something
that you can do well and it's, you have things for it.
And then it's, and then it's not as interesting
at that point.
It becomes a little less interesting.
And I think one thing I've been conscious of and it's,
and lately it's happened a little bit, you know,
it happened a few times where you don't become victim
to your past
successes by saying I got to go back out and show everybody,
Yeah.
Like.
Yeah, that was what I was gonna ask you.
(Laird laughing loudly) Like when you, you know,
hey, I'm the big wave guy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then somebody else goes,
Yeah, yeah.
finds another wave
and surfs a bigger one.
Yeah, yeah.
Do you feel like you got to get out there
and show them who's boss, you know, you're over here
tinkering in your garage
Yeah.
with new shit
but there's gotta be some aspect of you who's like
There is, but again, I think,
Yeah.
but that's where I said
having a good perspective about your ego's voice,
like what what is that in you that's doing it?
Yeah.
Like, why
is there something saying you need to go show these,
show people what you can do?
You did that and you've showed that.
And in a way I can do that.
And I do aspects of it, whether it's on purpose or not
but it doesn't bring me the kind of joy
or the kind of satisfaction or fulfillment
that doing something that I haven't done does.
And I start to realize, you know, that I really am inspired
by doing things I haven't done.
Like that's the more, whether it's a distance I haven't done
or a height I haven't done or speed I haven't done
or something
Yeah.
but something that I haven't done
is a lot more fulfilling.
That just brings you a lot more satisfaction.
What's it's freeing too because you're not.
It's free.
You're liberated
Yeah.
from measuring yourself
against past successes, right?
I mean, as somebody who (Laird laughs)
I mean you're already somebody who doesn't really care
about what other people think anyway which is healthy but,
(chuckles) That's helpful.
yeah, that is helpful (Laird laughing).
But at the same time, like I know when I go to the pool,
like, I don't wanna look at the pace clock
because I'm used to clocking certain kinds of intervals.
And I, you know, I'm not able to do that now.
So that it's.
Yeah.
It changes your life
That is set up.
and I'm doing it, yeah.
Yeah.
It's set up and it's like.
I have to constantly remind myself,
I'm doing this because it brings me joy.
You know?
Absolutely.
And what else can I do? Or can I do something different?
I'm not innovating in the sport like you are in surfing
but you have to recalibrate your relationship
to these things and not hold yourself to some standard
that's gonna cause you suffering, right?
Was it, yeah.
And I think by opting out
and just being like, well I'm gonna go do,
and then you're constantly
Yeah.
a newcomer.
You're new and you're always progressing and learning.
So you're getting fulfilled through that process.
And that's usually big
Yeah.
Improvements those are big
Right.
successes not from doing something that you can't do
to do to being able to do it.
That's a huge success.
You couldn't, you did.
Not, you did something at this level and you maybe
you're doing it that level.
Maybe not quite at that level.
I go that that's just a set up for failure.
And I, there's a great quote that I love that says,
"Never let your memories be bigger than your dreams."
And I have to say that I really,
I think that that's important because I have friends
that have played professional sports
and then they're retired
and everything's about what they did.
Right.
That's not
what they're doing
There's nothing
they're ever gonna do in their life
that's gonna recapture that.
No.
Like sense of glory of being in the Coliseum.
Right?
Yeah, I mean, how,
So how do you move forward?
Right?
So that's,
so, and that transition is pretty tricky, I think I've been
I know 28 (laughs).
Yeah, yeah.
By the way.
Yeah (laughing).
And there's probably, you know, there could be 40
or 50 more years.
Right.
(Laird laughing)
So, you know, and so I think that that's, you know
the irony is that maybe I didn't,
maybe early on I didn't get, I wasn't in the Coliseum
and I didn't get the glory but then I also don't get
the downfall of having gotten the glory.
And I can just kinda, it's kinda like it's a flat, you know,
it just kinda keeps
Yeah.
going along,
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
which, you know it's not on purpose.
It just ended up that that's how it's worked out.
And also knowing that you can go
and without approval, you can be fulfilled.
So I can go out and I can do something like I'm at a stage
right now where I can get a couple of friends
and we can go somewhere and we can do something
and no one sees it.
No one, there's not a video.
There's not a film.
There's nothing, no one even knows and it works.
Yeah.
And it's great.
And you come back and you feel like you feel
when you did something that everybody saw.
And everybody said it was great.
Or people saw and said it sucked, but you didn't.
So you almost, it's nice to be at that stage (laughs).
It's just for you.
Yeah it makes it a little bit more special that way.
That's pretty nice.
Yeah.
'Cause then you're, 'cause then ultimately
you're in, you know, that you're not relying
on the approval of other people which at the end
they really, truly really they don't care at the end.
Yeah. Yeah.
They really don't care
about you like you care about you (laughs) you know?
Yeah.
The funny thing about innovation is that it does require
a certain level of like foresight because we always think
we're at the end point of everything.
Like it's, everything is progressed to its ultimate
pinnacle already, right?
When surfing was at a certain competitive apex
with the short boards and all the compete, you know
like the competitions,
Yeah.
it was like, well there's nothing left to be said
or done here, right?
Yeah.
And to be able to think outside the box and say,
Well, what if we try this?
What if we try that?
requires a certain, you know, there's something very unique
about being able to see what nobody else can see.
Well, that's what I, and that's what I said to you
initially was having the understanding of what things mean.
Like if I make this glass right, if I have this thing
I think about it, I'm gonna make this thing
and it's gonna shape like that you're gonna be able to put
stuff in there, you know and you're gonna have to hold it.
And then you're gonna be able to drink out of it.
Like, but you got to see that, right?
You have to be able to see
what the function will be at the end.
'Cause that's the only way that you get the motivation
to actually continue the process.
'Cause it's a pretty R and D and that kind of development
that's some can be pretty discouraging.
Like there's some discouraging aspects to ideas that
and one of them is other people like the truth
is that there was a woman who
had some in, did some incredible innovation.
I don't even know her name or what she did, but I do.
I appreciated what she said, which is they asked her
you know, when you have a great idea, you know,
what should you do?
And she goes, just, don't tell anybody for at least a year,
(Laird laughs)
Yeah.
because they will discourage you.
They'll be like,
you know what, that cup thing that you have,
that's a terrible idea.
Yeah.
And it'll sink in and you'll be like,
and then when you break the first one and the second one
and the third one and--
She is right,
too hard (Laird laughing).
Too hard and then you stop
and then that's where, so I think there's a has to be.
And that's why I talk about dog with the bone, you know,
that relentless
Right.
thing that you're not really, it's not really a goal,
but somehow you're just constantly,
you just always go back to it.
You're like, oh, the thing.
And then you go back to it.
Now I have ideas that I've been thinking
about that had gone away from and then eventually
I come back over here and I'm like, "Oh yeah, yeah."
And then I go away and I do it, some other idea.
And then I go back to the one and then you just keep
and eventually that one just pops his head.
And, you know, I mean, I think everything's about timing.
I mean, we know that it's like you could do, you know,
a good idea, you know, 10 years ago
is not a good idea today.
Or, you know, there's ideas today that are,
that won't be good for 10 more years (laughs)
you know it's like,
Right.
It's just all, you know,
Right, right, right.
So yeah, I think the foiling thing is a good example
of that
It is.
because the technology is at a point where they can,
you know, make this available to consumers
with the electric foil.
I mean, that, stuff's crazy
Yeah.
Yeah, well just all of it.
It's suddenly out
of the blue, right?
Yeah.
So when you look back
It seems out of the blue,
Yeah.
but it's not, it's like
Even you're like not for me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah (laughs).
To be zero effort (both laughing).
Let's evaluate for only for 15 years he got out
I know,
but you know what?
We talked about that in success too, when the guys go,
hey the overnight success and the guys like,
hey, I have been doing this for 15, you know,
Right.
I've been doing it for 10
or 15 years.
It's like, you know what, it's interesting how that,
Yeah.
You know.
when you Look back though, you know, and think
about the early days of you getting up on standup
paddle boards when no one was doing it and now you look
around and everybody's doing it.
I mean, there has to be like a certain level
of satisfaction.
There is.
Like, I mean, you've created like this cultural
groundswell, like this populous sport that so many people
are doing because you thought, hey, I should get
a longer paddle so I can stand up on this thing.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, and I you know, and Gabby and I talk about it
and I think I, you know, for me, in a way,
those are my reward, you know, those are the rewards.
Those are the trophies that was,
that's like my trophy, like people are like,
I don't have a trophy case.
I don't have a bunch of things like, look at all my trophies
all my championships, all my stuff.
I don't have any of that stuff.
So in a way, those are, you know, those, that's fulfilling
Right.
when you see--
This incredible legacy.
Yeah.
Yeah so I see that
you get to see,
I mean, when you see a guy in Dubai with a turbine
paddling like that you're like
Yeah.
(both laughing) that was, that went a long way.
(both laughing hysterically)
That's wild.
That went
around the whole planet (laughing).
I was watching you foil on a Nazare.
And it's just wild to watch that.
And what was interesting is that it allows you to surf
the wave in a completely different, like you're not
reliant upon it cresting,
No.
like you're able to ride it much earlier
and it gives you this longer ride.
So it's a completely different relationship with the wave
that that technology, you know, makes available.
Yeah, it totally re, what's interesting we talk
about with, because of that we have to re,
like the definition of an unmakeable, a wave, you know,
an unmakeable wave is changed.
You know,
Yeah.
what was that makeable before now all of a sudden
becomes makeable or what was unrideable before
now it becomes rideable.
So the parameters all changed, which is interesting
how you you know, you just have a different device.
And now the way we look at waves and what's rideable,
like that's our biggest thing,
like looking there's new waves that are,
that would never be considered for surf,
for conventional surfing.
Now, all of a sudden,
the foiling
So the storm
is rolled up.
It opens up the whole
Yeah.
new set of circumstances
which is, you know, which in an ever populated earth
is pretty great when there's new frontiers.
And it can, I guess that continues to happen
and with a lot of innovations
but where there's this like a whole new frontier where like
in a world where everything's saturated, like all, you know
most of the great surf spots on earth, people know,
and they're at.
Right.
And they're surfing and those numbers are increasing.
And there's only so many ways now there, you know
now they're making wave pools and stuff
Yeah.
because to try
to make up for that.
But to be able to have a whole new, you know,
a whole new search gives you--
It's cool.
Yeah.
But I wonder, you know,
it wasn't until maybe a couple of years ago
that I'd even heard of Nazare.
Yeah.
Did that just, I mean, so it seems like in that
kind of timeline of iteration there was Makaha,
then there was Waianae then there was Maverick's
all of a sudden then it was about third reef Waianae,
then there was Jaws and then Teahupoo,
and then Nazare, right?
So it makes me think there probably is another wave
out there that no one's found.
There is.
That's awaiting
to be discovered.
There's always another wave.
I mean, Nazare in itself is a,
you know, it's a, there's a couple things
happening in Nazare, which is it's a very
photographable wave,
Because you get the foreground of the lighthouse
or whatever that.
And the angle of the cliff
Gives that descriptive.
Which shows you the bottom
Right.
curvature of the face.
And the wave also does a thing where it stands up
for a second.
It's not, I mean, and nothing against Nazare
but it's not an like an optimum performance surfing wave.
Like, Jaws is.
Like Jaws still at this moment
is the best big wave performance wave in the world?
There's just there's no, I mean, I don't care what big wave
you go to, you take all the big wave riders,
they'll all agree when you go to Jaws, you know,
I mean, the one thing about Nazare is that it has a,
there's a consistency to it.
And when it doubles up, it has a,
you know, kind of a geographical phenomenon
where the wave doubles up and two waves come together.
That's why they get that the extreme height of it.
So there's a lot of that around Nazare that
and it's in front of a cliff, so it's extremely dangerous.
But as far as surfing goes, like, as a surfer
you, usually that wave, you're like,
that's not an ideal wave for surfing.
Like, as a where Jaws, you wouldn't say that but the truth
is that Nazare wouldn't even be Nazare without towing.
That towing
'Cause you wouldn't,
even be able to like, right?
do it that's why
it wasn't a surf spot because towing opened it up
and made it become a sport.
So now it's a sport because it towing without towing
I mean, you can surf Nazare on the small days,
like conventional you know, prone paddling,
but it's not a,
It was not.
It's not it.
It's a--
Yeah.
And the foiling was it the break next to Nazare, right?
Yeah, well both Nazare and is there a wave
off the coast from Nazare that for foiling was perfect.
So, and actually it was probably great
on this last giant swell that they had,
but they weren't letting us into the country over there.
Right (laughs).
Yeah. When we were there, like in the spring.
Yeah.
Yeah. Well, I was there in what, February?
February, March? Yeah.
Let's talk about the fitness journey and the pool workout.
Legendary, it's been going on for a long time.
Yeah.
Lots of dudes, you know,
are part of that community.
I've got tons of friends who are either part of it
or have dropped in at some time
Yeah.
or another.
There's a, it's almost mythic at this point.
It begins with Don Wildman really.
Yeah.
So, let's talk about Don
a little bit.
Don, the King.
Yeah.
I miss Don.
So Don, one of my heroes is, will be, and always will be
was his and he's passed away.
But Mr. Wildman,
you know, started Bally's health clubs started.
Right.
Started, he is the founder
of the largest health club chain in the U.S.
Was in the Korean war when he was 17.
And did the iron man what didn't first one when he was 50
I think
Yeah.
did 10 or 11 iron mans.
And, you know, you used to do all the senior games in Utah,
all the bike racing stuff.
And him and I, I met him at a helicopter,
snow boarding resort in Canada.
Randomly, some guy just says, "Hey, that's Mr. Wildman.
"You need to meet him, go over there."
And so I said, hey, went over there and
"Hey, nice to meet you."
And he was sitting there and then cut to like two years,
three years later I was down in Malibu at a restaurant
that we breakfast and walked in there
Gabby and I had just moved there
and he happened to live right up the street.
And then him and I just started spending time
together and you know, doing a bunch of crazy things.
He just was an endurance monster.
Right.
And, you know,
and I worked out.
You could just destroy
anybody on a bike? Yeah.
Yeah, he just was a monster.
When it came to just, you know, suffering,
he was a King of suffering, loves suffering (laughs).
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So that was the original crew, right?
Yeah.
Like he had this spot
down at the beach
Yeah.
and then you guys would meet up there
And his gyms.
And do pull ups
and, right?
Yeah.
And his crazy gym he had a crazy circuit workout
that take you two and a half hours and then we'd ride
the bike,
Right.
after to go eat breakfast
and then I kind of brought all the water stuff to him.
So, it was like, he swam 'cause he, you know,
triathlons and stuff, but he never,
so I got him into foiling and stand up paddling
and all that kind of stuff.
And we, so we started, you know, venturing into the water.
Right.
And I did the race
across America with him or at least part of it.
Yeah, I remember that--
Yeah, we did part of that.
something happened,
Yeah.
like halfway in
We all got hit
and you ended up, right.
one of our teammates got,
run over by the opposing
Yeah.
team's escort vehicle, broke my friend's leg.
So that put us out of the race because we were trying to
Don was trying to break the record.
He just wanted to go break the record with a bunch of people
that no one heard of.
His like Forman team?
Yeah so, Forman really
it was.
And then you ended up like
paddle boarding down the Mississippi or something like that?
Well, I did the Colorado.
I did the Colorado.
Okay.
I've been down to Colorado
Yeah.
and standup paddle and but, you know, all that,
Right.
All that suffering.
I think we are our best one was we did, I call it
the Hawaii 500, but we biked every Island in Hawaii
and paddled every channel consecutively.
So we biked across the big Island like 120 530 miles
from South point to the tip.
And then we paddled the Maui.
Yeah.
Then we biked across Maui.
Then we paddled the Molokai.
Then we biked across Molokai.
We palled Oahu bike across Oahu
and then paddled to Kauai.
The last battle was 22 hours.
Wow.
So I peddled 22 hours on to Kuai.
That's intense.
Then we back, yeah,
Yeah.
That's was (laughing).
I did--
suffering (indistinct)
I did five iron mans on the five Hawaiian islands
Yeah, yeah.
in a row.
I thought that was bad-ass but I wasn't paddling
in between the islands (both laughing).
I took an airplane.
Yeah, I know, we--
You know.
But, so that was, we've had some, well I had some fun
with Don, Don and I--
And he was crushing it,
right? He passed at 85, right?
Yeah.
So he was crushing it
all the way, to the end.
To the day.
To the like
Right?
the last month he just, he tapered off and that was it.
He had some lung stuff with, I kind of feel
like maybe it was attributed to all those hours on PCH
you know, riding that bike.
Yeah.
And breathing heavy
with all those cars I think probably was in my mind,
I was just like something, but he, but, you know,
he went out like he wanted to,
Like, he was good,
Yeah.
solid to the end.
I think we had done a helicopter snowboarding trip
to Chile the summer before.
So that was pretty.
Wow.
That was pretty great.
At 84?
Yeah.
That's wow.
Yeah and I remember one of the guides we were down there
and one of the guides said, "How old, 'cause he was
he would snowboard and he'd go fakie,
which is when you flip around and ride the reverse stance,
which you know, the kids go fakie, right?
Yeah.
Like not that 80.
Right.
You know at 85-year-old.
Yeah.
At the age of 85 years
(laughs)
Yeah, I mean,
It's like, jackass, like Johnny Knoxville dressed up
Yeah.
as an old guy doing that.
Yeah, yeah,
You know?
But it's Don Wildman.
But it's actually the guy.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, wow.
So--
So what do you,
what did you take from that?
I mean, other than like, he just never stopped?
Yeah.
Right? Just staying in--
Well, a rolling stone gathers no moss, you know,
and a running car keeps running.
So I think, you know, I looked at Don as someone
that was a lover of life.
Like he was really like, whenever, you know, I remember
you know, we'd have dinner and he'd be like
"This is the best dinner I've ever had."
And then a week later he'd be over at the house
and "This is the best dinner I'd ever had."
And he would be, you know, his grandkids would send him
some radical hardcore music and he'd be playing it
in his porch and stuff.
And you know what I mean?
He was super,
But that's a beginner's mind
right?
Beginner's mind .
Yeah.
Crazy beginners mind
and willing to, I mean, when you're 80 something
you're still gonna, you're gonna be pretty
Yeah.
crusty in certain ways.
You're, you know, you're gonna you're, but he was willing
to subject himself to he'd always do new stuff.
I could get them if I said, you know, I go,
"Hey, you wanna go dive with the sharks?"
"Oh yeah, sure, great."
"Hey, you wanna go skydive?"
"Oh yeah", "Hey, you wanna go sail on the Americans go."
"Oh yeah."
I mean, it's like, I'd invite him on the most random stuff.
He always said yes.
Unless he had some other plans already
and was willing to subject himself to that,
you know, that learning curve.
Yeah.
And his name was actually Wildman, you know?
Which is the best part.
Yeah.
People that look at me call him the Wildman.
I go, well that's the thing
(Rich laughs loudly)
like Donahue Wildman.
This is perfect.
Perfect, you can't make it up.
That's what I'm saying. You can't make that stuff up.
So for me, I think to know him it was interesting
'cause I've had friends that have passed away
that I had remorse for.
And Don was one of the first guys that I'd ever
I didn't feel bad about him, you know, I mean,
of course I miss him and we think about him all the time
and talk about him but I didn't miss him
like I had other friends 'cause I didn't,
there was nothing I felt like that
No stone unturned, right?
No stone unturned.
Yeah.
That he was, it was all good.
And he crescendo like he wanted to, he wanted to go out,
you know, being the guy that you remember
and not withering away.
Right.
And I think so, I think all of that,
I think that it really, it was like remorse levers.
Like there was no remorse.
There was no,
Right.
which was pretty great, I'm like,
if I can live a life like that, where you know,
where people around you feel like there's nothing, you know,
there's nothing remorse,
okay, hey, you missed a couple of people you miss.
And of course in some of this stuff that you leave behind
people that are hurt, but, and that's gonna,
there's no way out, you know (chuckles)
Yeah.
without that happening.
But that kinda lives on
Lives on.
in what you do now
with the pool work out, right?
It lives on, yeah.
Yeah.
And you know, I think for me, you know I always,
I get bored easy and I think connected to the innovation
and I don't, I try to get out of ruts.
I like to try to keep learning and getting taxed,
you know like getting taxation from the learning.
You know, I told somebody when you ever, you know
when you learn something, how sore are you?
And then, you know, after you've done it for six months,
how less sore are you?
And when you've done it for a year
you're not even sore anymore.
It's like the first time you run a mile, you're like
you feel like you're broken.
And then you got to run two
and then pretty soon you got another 10
and then pretty soon you got to run 50.
It's like, there's no, you just have to keep building where.
So I think there's something about that,
about doing new things.
And the pool really came out of my disdain
for like traditional swimming.
Like, you know, I'd be like the Orca with the floppy fan.
Yeah.
You put me in the pool
and make me swim and I feel like I need, you know,
I love in the ocean and mask and fins and, you know,
seeing and being moved.
And so, you know, a lot of my pool, the pool stuff really
was a marriage between the gym and swimming.
Like how could I marriage, you know,
Yeah.
light weightlifting
and swimming and which resulted in kind of a pretty
you know, and then we'd throw in heat and ice
and some other, you know,
Right.
Other kinds of exposure stuff
Yeah.
and breath work.
And just always trying to change it up, just looking for
you know, looking to make it new and interesting
and try to stay out of those ruts, you know,
Yeah.
'Cause they're easy
to get in and before you know it you're, you know,
you're the bottom
Right
sit on the ground (laughs).
And you can play around within the rut
and think that you're innovating
but you're still very much in the rut.
That's something that I definitely plead guilty to.
(Laird laughing)
You know, and I'll convince myself that I'm working
on my weaknesses, but I'm really not.
Yeah.
'Cause I really don't
I don't wanna work on the weaknesses 'cause that sucks.
Yeah. Yeah.
Right?
'Cause you're gonna not feel good.
No, that's true.
You know.
It's true.
But still, it all hearkens back to Hawaii
because the original, you know, pool workout is carrying
stones along the bottom,
Stones bottom.
you know running along the bottom of the ocean.
Absolutely.
Which is something
I've done it's not fucking easy (laughs).
Absolutely,
Well, and ultimately,
Yeah.
when you think about that dynamic of stone carrying
and running not a lot to do with swimming.
No, not at all.
It has a lot to do with breath holding and legs
and legs burn the most oxygen.
So whenever you incorporate dynamic leg in, you know,
you know, from the monofin or anytime you're using
getting the quads going, man, that
That's all, yeah.
The breathing,
the breathing goes way up.
It's jerked up fast.
I mean, you look at long distance swimming.
It's like don't move the legs (laughs) you know.
Drag them.
Drag them is gonna burn oxygen.
Dag 'em has no forward
Yeah.
propulsion is worth
the amount of energy expenditure
Exactly.
using your legs.
Exactly. Unless you have
Yeah.
some giant fins on.
Right.
And that's a different
discipline but so that a lot of it came out of that.
And then just first of all being in the water,
back to the water.
So we're back in the water, we're in the water,
breath holding, fear of drowning.
That stuff is really powerful.
That's right there with falling and being burned
and being eaten by giant animals.
Yeah.
So, whenever you deal
with that kind of psychology about holding your breath
underwater and you can't breathe underwater
no matter who you are yet.
So, that's a big psychology, right?
What that environment represents.
And then you can be, you know, you're in a pool at my house,
so it's pretty controlled.
So you can, then we can kind of ratchet the, you know,
there's some fear things that we can deal
with in that environment that, you know,
and then compression, you know, we learn about compression
and blood flow through the lymphatic system.
Yeah.
That, you know,
like in an hour, your body circulates the blood through it.
That normally it takes like 24 hours.
So you have something
It's a different thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah it's a different thing.
And then you can be really aggressive.
You know, I take some basketball guys
and we do a bunch of jumping work and all of a sudden
their verticals increase.
And you can take a guy that probably shouldn't jump a lot
'cause they're so giant
Yeah.
but they can jump hundreds of times
without all that impact.
Yeah, you remove that thing.
Yeah.
That's causing
all the injuries.
Exactly.
Right?
The momentum makes impact.
Creates these like supportive tissue around you.
Exactly.
And it also exhausts you more than anything.
I mean, there's something about whatever you're doing
in the pool, man, you will sleep well at night.
You will.
You know.
Yeah.
I don't know what that's
about, but you know.
Yeah.
I can go out and run for hours or ride my bike.
But nothing makes me as tired as being in the water.
Well, you, I mean, listen--
It's a tapped thing.
If they're saying a two and a half miles swim's
worth 125 mile bike and a 24 mile run,
that's they're telling you what the, you know,
Yeah.
the difficulty,
like you're saying like two miles,
two and a half miles is equivalent to these other things.
I think a lot of it is temperature.
Yeah.
I think the temperature
even if it's
Yeah, you're gotta regulate.
Well, yeah your water 70, even the water 70,
it's still not 98.
That's 30 degree, you know,
28 degree temperature difference.
That's over time
Yeah.
that, so I think there's that.
And then the psychology and then the breathing,
Yeah.
you know, and it's,
but we love the water work for that.
And for us, it correlates to our relationship
with, you know, being in the big ocean
and being in the big surf, you can move, you know,
one of my theories is that that you will gain technique
out of necessity, right?
Because if you to, in order to swim a giant dumbbell
across the pool, you're gonna have to be efficient.
Like and I don't care what your stroke looks like
and I can get a stroke coach and be like, well
you should move your arm to do your thing.
I'll go, here's a dumbbell swimming over there.
Yeah.
And if you could swim
You'll figure it out.
that number over there,
you're doing something right (Rich laughs).
You're learning, you're knowing it's kinda
like putting a giant pack on, you carry a huge pack?
And you take it off probably gonna be faster, you know?
Yeah.
It's like.
Yeah, yeah.
When you add the survival aspect into it, right?
Yeah.
Then i get
to the other side somehow.
Exactly.
And you're gonna use all your limbs to do it.
Anything you can to get there.
Well, it's also, it's still like,
it's not like anybody else's doing this, right?
So that it's so open-ended in terms of like the innovation,
I'm sure you're tweaking
What's amazing to me
it all the time, right?
It's amazing to me that,
it's not, that they're not, that it's not being applied.
Had hasn't been applied, you know, it's like one
of those things, like you'd think that, I mean
and I know from what you know and we're always
being creative now we're starting to be able
to kinda combine stuff.
So we have a couple different things
that we put them together, make hybrids.
So like circuit training like,
Yeah.
in weightlifting
have all these different techniques and then you start
to combine them and then you have yourself,
some new, you know, there's always a new.
Like a program.
Yeah.
Do you make the, you have like an app, right?
The XP.
We do, but--
XPT so you make that available to people?
But not the pool because the pool is so specialized.
Yeah.
The water is not something to go subject people to.
Don't sue Laird.
Don't (laughs) don't sue me.
Yeah.
No, yeah.
Basically, a liability.
The cool we need, I mean
Yeah.
we are very selective about we have trainers for XPT,
you know, for the fitness stuff, but for the pools
pool specific training we have very few people that we would
that will license to become a because of the water.
Yeah, dangerous.
So like it's not
this isn't something to fool around with.
Yeah.
And especially when you
have weight you know.
And throw in, you know, a 200 degree sauna
in between sets, right?
It is like.
And kinda cold plunge.
Yeah.
So it's like working
those protocols
Yeah.
into the actual workout itself.
'Cause you think of those as a post-workout thing, right?
Or a pre-workout thing.
But to drop that into the middle of the whole thing
creates like a whole different kind of stress.
Yeah, we've been doing some interesting stuff too,
like 'cause we're always looking for ways to,
you know, it's like, you know, run a mile, run two miles
but you have to keep making the thing longer.
'Cause you get kind of better at it you adapt, you know,
that we're sending adaptable creatures,
we adapt quickly to things.
So we shake it up but you know, one of the things
that we've been doing, I mean, we put the, you know,
we put the assault bikes in some of the other stuff
in the saunas.
Yeah.
But we do one of these protocols where we do,
where we ride some sort of cardio assault rowing machine
when it's something that you know, boosts your cardio.
And then we go into the ice plunge and we do
we go back and forth between those and that just
has a pretty profound effect on you (chuckles).
Yeah.
But it gives you
a good hammering,
Yeah.
but you know just when you think, we always say,
just when you think it was safe to, you know,
Right.
to do heat and ice
and do the thing (laughs) you gotta, you know.
Now it's gonna be this, right.
But I guess we do that out of more out of our,
kind of our interests are, you know, in our search,
our discovery, it's more out of discovery.
Like, hey, what if you do this?
Oh, that's cool, let's try that and see,
and a lot of it comes from that.
It comes from that innocent, you know,
that like that child, like, you know,
why are kids so good with certain things?
Like they get a you know, a phone
and they're all of a sudden doing everything.
Right.
'Cause they just,
they don't just go, well, what if I don't know if I should?
And you know, they just go into, and I think that's
healthy, I think it's
Right.
go about it, whatever you're doing,
it's like good chefs
or, oh, I didn't think that that curcumin would make that
dish better or whatever.
Right.
Just, you know,
Yeah, yeah.
it's just, and that's the same I think in innovation
is really, again, a formula it's like you can put it
in whatever you're doing, it doesn't I don't think there's,
I think the basic structure of it is the same,
no matter what genre you're in, just change the backdrop.
Like what is it fitness? Is it nutrition?
Is it sport? Is it art? Is it tech?
Is it, what is it?
It's like (laughs)
It's curiosity,
willingness to try things
Yeah.
and then take kind of remote taking failure off the table.
Right? It's not about that.
It's like, we're just, we're gonna pull on these threads
and see where it leads us.
For sure.
And failures are part of that process.
Yeah.
That's just your,
that's part of what you're doing.
That's
So you're what are you?
56 now?
Yeah.
56?
Like I'm 54.
So, you know, it's like trying to figure out how to continue
to stay fit, stay engaged, try new things.
But are there certain things where you're like,
ah, I can't do that anymore.
I've noticed this about like how I'm aging.
So I have to, you know, adjust like where are you at
with all of that?
Well, Most of the things
Are you just?
I'm doing is not so measurement oriented.
I don't have all those data stuff to use that against me.
(Laird laughing loudly)
Smart. Yeah.
There's some of that I don't have that.
Well, I only ran that mile at a while.
You know, I don't have all those numbers
that would probably show some deterioration.
I mean, I just think it's part of your nature.
Yeah, but you are also so attuned with your own body.
Yeah.
You know, where you're at
You don't need
all those things.
So, a lot of it is, you know, I guess for me,
a lot of it is I'm just not doing a lot of the same things
that I've been doing.
And I'm more, you know, a lot of my training really has been
not to hurt myself because in the past, a lot of times
you get your training injures you
and then you're kind of like, oh, that's not great.
So, lately it's been more about that, right?
It's a little bit more about okay, and you know,
I think the holistic thing is become, I'm better at it.
Like I'm better at my diet, my sleep, my workout
that's not hurting me.
My, you know, so I'm in a way I think, you know,
whether are my performances are you know,
I just don't have any real, tangible measurements
of you know, hey, I'm not as fast up the hill.
Yeah.
I mean, I know when I,
you know if I go get my 18, you know, my 18 year old protege
with me and I go up the hill, then he kinda disappears.
I'm like, well, I might not have dis, you know,
I might not be back here
Yeah.
for when I was 18 let's just put it that way but.
Is this guy Luca that's living with you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was hearing about this guy.
So he's a young, big,
Young, big wave rider
Big wave rider.
Yeah, from Half Moon Bay.
And you just took them in?
Well, yeah, like Gabby's thought it would be good for me
you know, since I'm in a house with all women.
So she,
Yeah, that's funny.
She met him and he was, you know,
young and full of testosterone and looking to be
an aspiring, it looks like he's an aspiring Seal
at this point.
So he's aspiring to become a Seal.
So I'm, I have a lot of friends that are in the Seal,
so that are out and in.
Yeah.
And so I've been exposing him to that.
So he has a better idea of what that will entail.
He's a big wave surfer.
He's a little bit of a throwback, pretty rare
type of person in this day and age.
He's kinda like, you know, like 1950s Cro-Magnum man
like a little bit like this is his,
the way his mind works.
And he has been good he's helps us.
He helps, you know, helps us at our home
with all the details because we have a lot of stuff going on
when you have, you know, daughters and people and stuff,
and just and train he's really been with us to train.
So he's been getting, and it's been nice to watch him
implement kind of our work and then see the results
that it's had on him.
Yeah.
And he's, it's made him strong.
So it's cool to see, to watch him pull train,
and you you know, do high X with gaps, circuit train,
pull train do all this stuff, breath work
and heat and ice and all that stuff.
And watch it, watch him kind of, you know, kind of benefit.
It seems like it's your way of paying forward,
what you received, right?
Like you, you, you know, you you've been the beneficiary
of having like strong men in your life
to be guiding forces from your stepdad
and Don and et cetera, right?
So now you can do that for this kid,
Yeah.
which is cool.
Well, I think that's ultimately, what do they say to
at a certain point after, you know, March on the ladder
maybe you, you either wanna be a King or a wizard, right?
Or you wanna be, whatever that looks like.
But I mean, and I don't mean a King
in the same of but you're just not one of the soldiers
fighting in the thing and that you can be,
it's more about a wizard.
I kind of like the wiz, you know, you're like the wizard
and the guys come to see you.
And I always thought that, like, when I was young
I wanted to be like this, like a you know, a guy.
The way you go see the wizard, he's in the barn over there.
(Rich laughs hysterically) Like you go,
It's like that though.
You know what I mean? Yeah.
This is pilgrimage up to your house.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You get to go see Laird
(Rich laughs) Go visit the wizard he's over there.
And it, you know, and not that I'm a wizard
by any means, but I do like that
'cause I have been that right in my life.
I've been like, hey, Jerry Lopez, you know
I like go to Jerry and Jerry be there.
And he's just ahead of you.
He's lived more, done more.
And then you go to him and try to get some insight.
And it's good for me if I can bestow some knowledge
that I've been, that was bestowed on me that helped me
go along my courses.
Yeah.
I mean, I think that, like you said, pay it back.
And I think that's, I think at the end, I think
that is really something that is that culturally we've lost.
And it really goes back to, you know, the Wiseman
that we you know, that they're supposed to be the wise men.
I'm not,
Right.
I'm definitely not me, not one of the wise men
but they're supposed to be these people that you
were supposed to look up to actually.
Right.
They're supposed to be
elders.
We Revere them
for their elderly
Yeah.
knowledge as opposed
to dismiss them and put them in a home.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And maybe that's just 'cause they survived.
That maybe that the knowledge is that they just
actually made it long enough to it live that long.
(Rich laughing) I'm just saying like, that might be,
it might not be anything tricky.
It just might be, hey, you can't be as like Wildman.
That guy is 60.
Yeah, you're not
gonna be around the World for 85 years
without getting some something.
Something's popping up.
And even if you can just observe the guy and be like, hmm
the way he does stuff, maybe that's something that,
you know.
Well, that's Hawaiian too.
Hawaiian, Hawaiian.
Right.
Hawaiian.
Yeah.
Which is more tribal, which is more of how we,
that the way the structure of culture has been in the past
is that you had to have, you wanted to have some elders
like the L whatever, the woman elder, man elder,
these elders that help the youth.
And because it, because I think that that's something
that we're missing.
I think the way
Yeah.
we look at elders, we kinda, let's just like you said,
put them in the, over there, out of our sight,
let's not and not realizing that there's a lot
to be learned.
Yeah.
And you see people that have admiration
for their grandparents and that go there and with their
I mean, they're, those are special people, right?
Yeah.
Those are special people
usually that have that have but also, you know,
I always say, 'cause you know in Hawaii we talk
a lot about respect, right?
It's always about, hey, you got to respect,
hey, you didn't respect me.
Well, I always say, yeah, but you gotta act respectfully.
So act respectfully, and then you get respected.
So, you know, I think it's important that the elders
act respectfully and then they can be respected.
But if the elders are not acting correctly.
Not behaving themselves (laughs).
Not behaving then it's no I'm just saying
and that's part of the issue too,
Right.
that we've culturally right?
Is the elders aren't behaving correctly,
then it's hard to respect them because you're like,
well you guys aren't even behaving correctly
so we're not gonna.
But maybe they're not
behaving well because they've been disrespected too.
You know?
Exactly. Exactly.
And we have lost that.
Exactly.
I mean, I, you know, I'm reminded of Julie,
my wife's father, she grew up in Alaska.
Yeah.
He was an engineer.
He moved the whole family up there.
And he was having the most success
like in the very late years of his life.
Like he, it got to the point he's like 89.
He could barely see.
And he would keep getting hired on these jobs because,
Knowledge.
The Native American culture
respected him and they're like, we'll send,
we'll come and pick you up.
We just, we need you and we want you there.
Yeah.
Like he was the wise man.
Right? And even though he's like, "I should be retired."
Like he just couldn't quit.
Yeah, but how great is that?
And there's some are really
beautiful about that.
How great is that
that you're the most needed at the end of your life?
You know, we were talking because I was reading
some Adlerian thing that I really enjoyed.
And they, you know, they were talking about that sometimes
the value is just the presence that the value
is just the presence that just being there
Right.
is the value
'cause people well, what value to they do?
And I go, well, listen, at a certain point
if the elderly can't do anything just their presence,
that they're there,
Yeah.
your grandma's there, your grandfather's there.
They're just, they exist.
And that can be enough to be a value, right?
Yeah, beautiful.
'Cause they're talking
about everybody being a value and you're like,
Right.
they're a value.
They're there (laughing).
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know?
All right, I wanna know how you live with all these women.
Like I got (chuckles) two daughters around we got two sons.
Oh, yeah, we get the same age too.
They're older.
Okay.
They're great.
Yeah.
They were easy.
Girls?
Girls were are trickier.
Complicated.
Right?
You know, I guess,
'cause I've been going through different stages of it
and you know, for I was describing my position
is kind of like being a post in the house,
like a giant post that holds the roof up.
You just have to be there.
You don't move, you hold the roof up so the roof
doesn't fall down and that's your position.
All the chaos (laughs).
Everything's going
around you, but you're just standing like that.
And you, and they need you to be there stationary like that.
But one thing about, I mean, listen the only thing I know
is I don't know anything.
I know nothing when it comes to--
I'm coming to appreciate that
to the girls.
idea, yeah.
They're complex like, and I think one also two the,
it's a complex time,
Yeah.
you know, on top of it.
I think it's not, you know, now the social pressures
and I think.
So hard to be a teenage
girl.
In your, and then it's,
because it's 24 seven, it's not just when you go to school
at school or when you go to the playground
at the playground, it's not just at these places.
It's all day long every day.
All the time.
And I think that there's a lot of pressure on them.
And, you know, I think I, you know, for me, I feel like
I try to lead by example and I'm pretty,
I mean, it's all about honesty like stop talking about,
you know, I have this conversation with my youngest daughter
about makeup, and then she's like, okay, make, I
wanna get some makeup.
And I go, okay, well, you know why you're gonna
you want to put makeup on, right?
And she goes, "Well, because it makes me feel good."
I go, "No, you wanna put makeup on to attract males."
Like, and (laughing) and you wanna you're trying
to attract a male.
And she's like, no one makes me feel good.
I go, what makes you feel good because that you think
it might help you be attractive.
That's part of why you're doing it.
So it was (indistinct)
I think it's even more
complicated than that because (Laird laughs)
she's on social media
and she's seeing other girls
Yeah, yeah.
her age doing that.
Yeah.
And you wanna feel like you're part of that
or you can fit in with that.
Yeah.
And there's like
a self-esteem thing that yes is about,
But it's about attracting too.
But it's also about signaling to the tribe
and where you fit
Yeah.
and all of that.
Yeah. Yeah.
No, but that's the complexity of it, right?
It's like, hey, you're doing this to fit in, to do it
to fit in with the girls that you're other girls to fit in
to be attractive, because that's ultimately
whether you're being attractive to the girls
that fit in or not.
I mean, that's all part of that pressure.
I'm just saying that I just want her,
I wanted her to understand that there was another motive
than just
Right.
her at the house.
Right. Right. Right.
Yeah, I get it.
Like you know, for herself.
Yeah.
It's not just for you.
It's for, you're doing it for other people.
Yeah.
So,
It's not easy man.
No.
I feel like Kids either define themselves
by trying to model the behavior or the example that you set
and and like kind of covet approval that way.
Or they define themselves in opposition to who you are.
Like, I'm gonna just contravene everything that you're
about to create some distance.
And maybe that's an attention thing.
I don't know.
But I'm dealing with a little bit of that right now
where it's like everything that we're about not interested.
By that you hate the beach.
I hear that you have like,
your daughter's gonna come to you and wanna ask
about life advice.
Like that's not happening (laughs).
No, no, no.
Not quite.
I'm trying to figure out
Hate the beach, yeah.
like what the right thing to do is, yeah.
You model, you set an example, you model the behavior,
but you have to have a very loose relationship
with the results of that.
And you gotta be able to roll with stuff
that like you didn't expect.
Well, I have a feeling that you're not gonna see
the fruits of your work until they leave.
That a lot of the seeds that you plant
and a lot of the things that you do,
you won't see until they go out of your house.
And they have their, and because those seeds,
whatever it is that you've planted those are growing,
but you can't see them.
Right.
And the thing that they're gonna turn into is gonna come
after, it's gonna come after it's gonna come late.
It's gonna come, I mean, I can speak for myself personally.
Like how
Yeah.
that later on
I was like 25
or something like that, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah and then I have a 17 and 12,
but it's like I think a lot of those fruits
are gonna come later on.
You're gonna see, it's gonna be, you know,
they're gonna, you're gonna, you wish you would get
to, you know, reap the rewards of it,
but there's none of that.
Yeah.
Right? There's none of that.
No. No. No (laughs).
There's none of that.
That's deferred for who knows how long?
Who knows how long?
You just hope that they come,
Yeah.
that comes out but, you know, I see it happen, you know,
where the girls will go, well, you know, one of my daughters
will go be with some family and then they come back
and know the family would be like, oh, she's so amazing.
So helpful. So great.
And I'm like, I'm like.
I know I have (laughs).
Was that odd?
We are talking
about the same person?
(Laird laughing)
Yeah (laughs), I know.
You know, my daughters hate the beach.
You know, like, all the beach,
how I hate the beach.
So do mine.
Hate surfing, hate turfing
Yeah.
Hate the beach. Hate working out.
You're eating that.
God set it up that way.
Crazy. I have a couple
So that they can be
your teachers.
Yeah.
I have a co, I have,
Gabby doesn't like it when I say that, but I'm like, yeah.
I said, your children were sent here to wear you out.
And so you can die and they can take over.
And then she's like, oh yeah, that's now that's
(both laughing) And then my other thing is, I said,
parenting is like building a samurai sword.
You take the steel, you heat it up, you beat it
with a hammer and you stick it in a bucket of ice.
And you just do that over and over.
And eventually it's the hardest steel in the world.
I said, parenting, a parent you take the kids take you
they heat you up.
They beat you with a hammer and they stick you in ice
and they do it over and then you're tempered,
like when you're done parenting you're gonna be like,
you're gonna be tempered, either that (Laird laughing)
or you're done break.
Broke or you break.
Breaking in half and you're done.
Throw you back in the furnace.
Right. So you've been, you and Gabby
have been together for over 20 years.
Yeah we around 25.
Yeah.
We're coming up on 25.
And you've kind of modeled this, you know, relationship
in a public facing way, which is interesting, you know,
like the way that the dynamic that you guys have figured
out for yourself, I think is super inspiring in that.
And you know, my wife and I are, you know, we strive to do
this ourselves is that, you know,
you're both very independent people.
You're not defining yourselves, you know, by, you know,
what the other person you're not relying upon each other
to define who you are, right?
There's a mute, there's a respect.
You come together when you come together, it's quality
but you both have your kind of independent worlds
and you provide the space for you guys
to have those experiences.
And they're not loaded in the way
that a lot of relationships are.
Where it's like, yeah I want you to be that guy who goes out
and surfs big waves, but only on my terms, right?
(laughs softly) Yeah.
And that's hard
Yeah.
to get to that place.
Yeah, I, you know, I think both Gabby and I
probably our childhoods, the relationships that we saw
around us growing up, or the lack of, you know,
one of the two, I think that had a big influence on us.
I, you know, I know that, you know, we talk about, you know,
each of us are responsible for our own happiness, you know,
that I'll go get happy.
You go get happy.
And then when you're happy and I'm happy you come back
and we'll both be happy together kind of thing.
Like not putting the pressure of, you know, I'm fortunate
that she's,
you know, and I guess she could say
she's fortunate that I'm completely, you know,
a fan of, you know, of Gabby's in her corner
and support her in things that at times
probably I wasn't exactly stoked about,
that it was more important for me to be supportive of her
than it was for me to vote my opinion
or my feelings about it.
I think that was a big piece of it that I would always
and she's amazing that she doesn't ever put the like
any of my passion
or my draw as something against her.
It's not taking away from her
Right.
as something like,
oh you did, but it's taken away from her.
And so, you know, the combination of but we, you know,
it's funny 'cause we were, you know, we've talked
about this before in the past that it's like her and I think
we have enough, we were scared enough of each other
that we're like, it's a cold war.
You know, it's a cold, we have a cold war.
We're just, we know that we both have nukes.
We both could drop them.
Right.
It won't be good.
You could die from the fallout.
Usually a sheer destruction (both laughing).
It's sheer destruction for everybody,
no matter who fires.
Let's not fire that and keep that in.
So I think that's been, you know, and we've had our
you know, we've had our ups and downs
like every relationship
Sure.
and every effort.
And I think, I mean, every it takes effort
in the relationship to make it, but you know,
they did a study with 10,000 couples and they said
that the only thing that was consistent
amongst all successful couples no matter what the dynamics
were was that the man respected the woman.
And so for me, that was, you know, I have a ton of respect
for Gabby as a person and then as a woman and then as a mom
and as a, you know, just all of her as a person.
And so, and I had also had a great relationship
with my mother and I have a lot of respect
Yeah.
for my mom.
My mom was a hardworking lady and, you know,
raised some children and some men too.
And so I, you know, I have that, I think that
and I can, I don't think that any,
just any guy could be with Gabby.
I mean, men have a hard time sometimes with women
that are strong because they just,
they either you're insecure
Yeah, I mean,
she's pretty alpha.
I would think that she
Yeah.
checks the alpha box.
You know and that many are category in your relationship.
Yeah and which is great.
And you have more that you can be more of the Teddy bear.
Yeah.
Affectionate guide.
This mystical.
Yeah.
Well, you call me in when it's, when you need
some real dirty work done and you know (both laughing).
You know what I mean? When the toilet breaks you call me
Yeah, I get it.
or when there's a bear
outside or can't help like (laughs loudly).
But she's, I mean, she's a force of energy.
Yeah.
When she walks into a room.
You've got to reckon with that.
That's, you know what I mean?
Yeah (laughs).
Which it's great.
I think, I don't think I would be able to respect her
if she wasn't.
I don't think, I think that--
That's her power.
Yeah.
If she didn't have that,
I would be, it would, I mean I would respect her
but it wouldn't be the same, like I do.
Yeah.
I wanna talk about Laird Superfood.
Okay.
You guys just took this company public, right?
We did.
I saw pictures of you like ringing the bell
at the stock exchange and it's just like a fish
out of water thing.
Hard to believe.
I know, it's wild.
I actually got to ring the bell
for Wildman when he, when Valleys when they,
Oh, wow.
But so I was able to, but I had
Your second time.
nothing to do
with it.
This is a whole different thing.
This has got my name on it.
Right.
And the fact that we were in a position that the business
has been, you know, built like it has been
and run like it has been is the only reason
why we were able to go public.
So that was a an education.
So I was in go public.
It's no small thing.
School.
Yeah.
That's it.
Well, just the whole process is it is amazingly
elaborate, complicated, like it's a complicated,
I wonder how come as many companies do,
are like given all there is to do and the details.
And I mean we're fortunate and enough to have great people
that was, you know, that was taken care of.
Well, I think it, I mean, obviously it suits you perfectly
because it's so part and parcel of your ethos.
It's really just a manifestation of you and your lifestyle.
It's dying that's the irony (laughs loudly).
I'm just saying, that's the irony, yeah.
What's that weird thing like,
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
you know, you mature
into something that you're not right?
Like the idea that you're in New York city at all,
Yeah.
Like I know you spent a year
there when you were a kid but like that's oil and water.
Yeah.
But when I look back over
the course of your career, like you're somebody who's
done lots of deals and had licensing and you've had
Yeah.
this product
and that product and some of them work,
some of them didn't work.
And I've always looked at it at an arms length
from a distance and not really knowing anything,
thinking like he just needs to get with the right partners
'cause this guy has got so much to offer
and maybe he's not partnering with the right people.
So I look at Laird Superfood, I clearly he's with the right
people and this is working.
Yeah.
And it's like,
to me it feels like long overdue that you should have
a win like this
Well, I appreciate that.
Like a long time ago.
I appreciate that.
You know, again, it's all about timing.
I think the timing of it, I think it's, you know,
I mean, it's like anything, maybe you, I might not have
been in a position to appreciate it like I am now.
Like you are, right?
You know, big if it was earlier or and maybe it just,
it wouldn't have wouldn't be what it is if it, if it hadn't.
So I think that's a big piece of it.
It's like the timing of it.
I, if I had to say, hey, when, you know, you get to choose
whenever it was gonna happen, the way it's happened
in the and the truth is that, you know, Gabby and I talked
about this before, you know, we've been very cautious
about who we align ourselves with throughout our careers
Yeah.
and just about what brands
and is it reflective of our brand?
And all those kinds of things and the truth is that we had
to, you know, ultimately build a brand
that was reflective of our brand.
Right?
And that's it.
and there were that's we were able to, but that's the truth.
The truth is, is that
You want to do it right
Yeah.
you can do it yourself.
Well, we just, 'cause there was no one
there was no business that we could think of that really
truly reflect reflected our, you know, our brand
and like this does because it is our brand.
So it's,
Yeah
So I think that's a big piece of it.
And, you know and again I always look at ideas
like all ideas and you know
and Superfood is one of them that, because everybody's
we're all so caught up in monte,
it's all about monetary, right?
My hand is,
how many this and how much that and all that stuff.
But I always think that it's about ideas, right?
And so if you think about how big is an idea, right?
What let's just say, how big is the idea of Facebook?
Pretty big idea.
Was this an idea?
What was the idea of, well, I'm gonna connect people
and the thing, and then you've got Facebook, right?
So how big is any of these,
how big is, you know, how big an idea is the Apple phone
or how big of the idea is, you know, stand up paddling
in my little world or how big an idea is, you know,
whatever the idea is and the other stuff comes later,
but the idea itself, you know, what is that like?
What is the nucleus of the idea?
And I think that's,
So with this,
determines the potential,
the ideas,
Right?
Yeah.
So with this the ideas, how do I get people eating better?
How do I get people
Please.
eating healthy?
How do I get people excited about eating healthy?
Please? How do I get stuff in people's diet that aren't?
Like people are out there that aren't eating well,
like they don't even have an opportunity to even understand
Right.
What eating well is.
You never heard of tumeric,
Ever.
which by the way you promised
Yeah.
fresh tumeric from Kuai.
Ever (laughs).
But you know what I mean?
I'm just saying like, they don't have any idea
or the resources or the availability or all those things.
So I think that's, so it's really about that idea.
And I think, you know, it's in our nature,
especially Hawaii, where Aloha is really about helping
about sharing, like sharing culture.
I mean, we have other things about it, but one of the things
that I was gifted when I was a kid was that I was shared
with, you know, that you, that there was a lot of Aloha.
That Aloha is sharing.
And Ohana.
Yeah, and Ohana exactly.
So the, but that, I think how, you know,
I think it's about ideas at the end that all of this stuff
is about ideas.
And then what, you know, and then seeing
how big the idea is.
What's the potential of an idea?
It's like, I mean, everything we have going on right now
every company that you see, I mean, our country,
or just everything.
Everything's about ideas and the potential
of what they can be.
And then, you know, trying to maximize that,
how big, how, you know it's like the idea of towing
and now you have Nazare, it's like,
Right.
things just appear
to reflect a concept so.
Yeah.
But--
Yeah it's a trap, man.
So in this case though, you're not going into an office
and managing people, right?
Well that's not my skillset.
Yeah, that's not your thing.
Like you're formulating
I have a partner.
Right.
Who does that very well.
So he that's his gift that we have and we're attracting
where we attract good people.
Like we just, it's the, you know how that is.
I have a thing I used to tell Gabby that they can call it
a honey line, which is, you know, when you see a bee,
you follow the bee and then another bee.
And then pretty soon you're at the hive.
And that's where the honey is.
It's like,
Yeah.
so good people attract good people.
So we have, you know, we have we're attracting
really good people.
You know, the majority of what I'm involved in is just,
of course always products, like what we're,
and then marketing because it's what we've done.
Gabby and I've been marketing for our careers.
We have to be self marketing 'cause our platforms
were so tiny.
You know, we talk about our the size of our platforms
have been so, you know, volleyball and surfing.
Those are little platforms.
And so you gotta be pretty creative to survive in those
you know?
Yeah.
It's not like you know, NBA or NFL where you just,
No, it's different.
You know (chuckles).
But you both transcend those subcultures.
Yeah.
Like you know,
you can both go by your first name.
Yeah.
People know who you are
and you stand for an idea that's much larger
than your sport.
Yeah, yeah and I think we've been fortunate
to be able to do that too.
Yeah.
Right? So there's, it's a combination that, you know,
and I tell young athletes all the time I go, "hey, listen
"if you, it's important for you to know how to talk."
It's important for you to know how to behave in public
in a way it'll bring you a lot more opportunities
'cause you can be great, a great athlete
but if you can't talk and you don't know how to act,
you're gonna have a limited potential.
Sure.
And you can
actually be not as good and have and be well-spoken
and know how to conduct yourself.
And you'll have a pretty good, you know,
you'll have a better opportunity to actually, you know,
make a living from it.
I think young athletes intuitively understand that
Yeah, well now.
because it's
all about social media and developing this platform, right?
Like it's not just, oh, I'm on this team.
Yeah.
Like they understand
they have to take responsibility for their career trajectory
and they can be riding the bench
and become the most popular--
Yeah.
Or important player because they've figured out
how to get people to care about what they have to say.
And that's new.
Well, but they're also
seeing the chain racks too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're also seeing the train tracks too.
So they're seeing the boat.
Yeah.
They're seeing the instantaneous failure of greatness
and then they're seeing the success of subpar, right?
Right.
So you're seeing both.
So they're having, there's a you know,
they're getting a pretty good spectrum of you know,
what not doing it right or what doing it right looks like.
So there, you know, 'cause we're at the end,
we always talk about monkey see monkey do, right?
We're the, that's what humans are.
We, when you see it, it's hard to be the monkey
that doesn't see and does.
That's always the trick but inevitably, you know, there's,
when we say there's nothing new,
just a new application of an old idea.
Yeah.
So, to think
you're the first person to ever think of something
or do something.
I always find that pretty arrogant.
'Cause it's like, no, that's not honest.
Honest is there's, it's probably a combination of, you know
something or some other thing that's been done in some way.
And then you're just making a hybrid
Right.
and combining it
and you know (laughs).
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's cool.
Building from it.
On that note, you being the wizard and all these people
making this pilgrimage to your house for the pool workout.
(chuckles) that simple rule.
There's an aspect of it.
I mean,
Yeah.
there's some interesting cats
that roll through that.
Right?
Yeah.
And I would suspect that that's its own Manhattan project,
right? Like you have a lot of really compelling people
doing interesting things in the world
that you're spending quality time with.
Pretty amazing.
I would suspect you've learned quite a bit
from this cast of characters, right?
Like what does that look like for you?
Pretty amazing.
Yeah.
Pretty amazing, you know, sometimes Gabby
just, you know, shakes her head whether it's, you know,
I mean, we, you know, I reading something or some book
or something and then it's next week, hey, so-and-so wants
to bring such and such
Yeah.
the guy that wrote that book or, you know, this
(Rich laughing) so we get a lot of that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know, we get a lot
of that, but you know, I feel like again the honey line,
or even in nature, when you're observing
then you get to observe more.
It's I think when you're interested in these subjects
and you're interested in health and wellness
and you're interested in fitness and you're interested
in longevity and you're interested in performance
and you're interested in morality and whatever you're,
I mean, you're just interested in these things and you're,
meeting people that are interested in them.
Right, yeah, there's David Sinclair showing up today
And then they know somebody that knows somebody
and then you have those guys.
And then so we get,
you know, the truth is we get
a really amazing array and diverse from generals to,
you know, athletes, to perform as peep to doctors.
You know, we're, I mean, we get mathematician.
Right.
I mean, we just get
it's like the spectrum because what you realize is that,
that it doesn't, you know, I always tell,
I always say to people I go listen, "Being a surfer's like
'being alcoholic."
Everybody's one.
It's just whether you drink or not.
Everybody's a surfer it's just whether you surf or not.
So what I'm saying is is that everybody
there's somebody in every field that's into health
and wellness and learning and creativity, right?
And no matter what field they can be lawyer, doctor
the, you know, politics, whatever they, but there
so that's your, what you have in common.
And so once you start meeting those people and then you got
you know, you got your friend Rick Rubin and he say
he knows 38, like, hey you wanna meet this professor
of so-and-so.
Right.
Like, "sure".
Now I go down to his house, I meet the guy.
And then the guy goes, "Oh yeah, I have another guy."
And he said, and then before, you know, you're like
all of a sudden, you know, the world's a tiny world
when you don't know anybody, right?
I mean, the world's tiny when you don't know anybody
when you know people it's like you're,
it's your, it's the next door.
It's the next room.
It's like, it's even smaller.
So when you don't know anybody, it's small
when you know people
Yeah.
it just becomes, especially like-minded people, right?
So when you have all these, you know,
when you have all these smart people that are interested.
Because when you realize the common denominator
in all those that group, learning.
They all wanna learn.
They're all interested and 'cause all the smart people
are people that learn.
That's what they do.
Yeah.
That's why they're smart 'cause they're always learning
and like, hey, what's this and what's that?
Oh, you're doing that?
Oh yeah, okay, you know, and you just see that
and that seems to be the common thread, right?
It's like, you never wanna, you never want absolutes
and you don't want anybody that thinks they know.
As soon as the guy says, "Oh, I know" you're like, right.
Yeah.
That's not the guy
I'm sure you've had (Laird laughing)
the guy who shows up who's full of VIM and vigor.
And like he's gonna
Oh yeah I gave those
to Gabby,
He's gonna is a dick
measuring contest.
I get those at Gab,
Gabby takes them into the deep end (Rich laughing).
She takes them in the deep end.
And, you know, first we give, first, you know, Gabby,
a girl, a woman takes him over.
So then they think, oh yeah, I'll have a real fighting cats.
Not realizing that, you know, she was raised by dolphins.
And so she's over it (both laughing).
So, but yeah,
Al right.
you know, I mean, I always I think it's like a mirror,
you know, he's like a mirror.
If the guy comes with, you know, a little edge
Yeah.
and you just give
him an edge.
Right.
Right (laughing loudly).
He's gonna get what he came for, right.
For sure we won't let you down.
Cool, man.
Well, I wanna be respectful of your time
Yeah.
and let you go here.
But maybe before we do that,
given your unique
skillset and life experiences and adventures
and everything that you've, you know,
experienced your whole life,
you have a unique lens on the world.
Like when you look at how most people live their lives
it's very different from how you live your life.
And, you know, being conscious of the fact that
most people don't have the luxury of being involved
in the kind of things that you are.
What do you? Like what's the advice like if you could
just reach your hand out to the average, Joe, who's,
you know, doing the normal thing of, you know,
working the job and paying the bills
and raising the two kids, like what is it that you want
that person to understand about life that perhaps
they're myopic to or can't see?
Well, that's a very tough thing.
I, you know, I have a friend called me the other day
and you know, and obviously the time that we're in
is a heavy time right now.
And some people it's real hard on and some people
it's not as hard on but it's a real kind of time
of uncertainty, right?
Where, which they always are but this one is overtly
uncertain, right?
Yeah.
This is very overtly uncertain (chuckles).
And he said, you know what,
he just asked for some advice.
And I'm like, I'm not in a position to give advice,
but I said, you know, I did say, you know, be honest,
work hard
and try to have fun, like you know, like, but there's,
I think there's something about remembering
that there's still these foundation things about, you know,
it's important to be honest.
You just gotta be honest.
We all have to be honest, honest, honest.
I think honesty in relationships and friendships,
in work and in life, I think there's, you know,
and just all the things I think that that's and I
and work hard.
I think we've got the, I think there's no way to, I wish
there was a way to you know, I mean, to work hard, you know,
I always Wildman and I used to laugh
'cause he was retired since he was 50.
And, but if the amount of work he did every day
compared to people that work, you couldn't even begin.
And then also you got to have empathy for the people
that you know, that everybody's got a burden, right?
So everybody has a burden.
And I think we have to be conscious that we've got to,
you know, lately I've been trying to operate more
with more tolerance and more kind of, you know,
just a more, just be aware that there's people
are under a big thing,
Yeah.
but we, and you gotta go you gotta figure out
how to have fun.
You gotta have fun.
If we don't have fun it's all, it's not worth it.
It's like, like I said, I'd just say, go surfing.
But I meant like, just do things, do something that
brings you
Yeah.
some sort of enjoyment.
Your version of surfing.
Yeah.
Whatever that looks like.
Yeah, it's there, everybody has their thing.
And I think, you know, I think too, you know,
when we're if we just can focus on the, you know,
it's kind of like I mean you know this better than anybody,
you know how when it's far what are you doing?
You're just looking at the next step.
You just keeping your eye.
You're not looking at the distance and going,
man that mountain is far away, you just look down
and you just keep, keep, keep your feet going.
And before you know it, you're like,
"Wow, I'm at the mountain now."
But if you're looking and I think that's a big piece of it
I think right now, I'm just, yeah.
I mean, it's enough to try to just, you know,
live sufficiently today.
Right.
It's enough effort to just work today, do what you need
to do today, take care of your family,
the people you love today, just keep your head down.
And that and I think that a lot of the stuff that
I think less of the stuff will bother you.
And then a lot of this stuff will be behind.
Yeah.
Or they will go behind.
It's hard though when the pressure's on.
And you're putting that one foot in front of the other
to feel like you can adult yourself with play or having fun.
I know that and that's why there's a balance aspect to it.
I think that that's where you're looking.
That's the balance of it, right?
Because all that stuff, you know?
And I don't, I mean, that's why people are, you know,
going to bars is 'cause they're trying to get that release
but you just have to figure out a way to get that release
that's productive, not destructive.
And so if you can just because that's the balance,
the equilibrium, because if all work and no play
makes Johnny a dull boy,
Yeah.
it's just not getting you just can't.
You have to figure out what that is whatever that, you know,
I mean, tell people it can be as simple
as just going to a movie.
So they just get to lead there.
Some were, you know, you do meditate, do some breath work.
I mean, you'd go for a swim, go for a bike
go for a Bingo, go for a hike.
You go on the sauna and, you know, boil your brains
go in the ice tub
Yeah.
and freeze yourself.
Something, something, something just something to create
some sort of
Shock you out of the roots
now a little bit
Yeah, yeah, yeah (chuckles).
Yeah.
Just to create a little bit
of tilt on the other side.
'Cause all these other stresses are just gonna,
they're just pulling us, they're pulling us down, you know?
Yeah. Yeah, I get that.
All right, last thing.
What's the wave
that still remains on surf?
Like the metaphorical wave.
Like what's still out there that you're thinking
about right now.
And you're laying brick by brick that maybe
we're not gonna see it for five years,
but it's on the brain?
Well, I'm definitely have a project to go out
in the, go out into some sort of, you know, stuff you see
on you know, national geographic when the ship's going
into the big, you know, whether it's down in the roaring
forties or up in the North Atlantic or out in the Aleutians,
but some project to go out into the big ocean
and ride the big ocean
Oh, wow.
out at sea.
So that's something that's in my head.
Has anybody ever done that?
I'm working towards.
No. No, I don't, I probably shouldn't want to.
Yeah (Laird laughing).
(laughing) Just out in the North Atlantic
in the middle of the ocean.
This is some of the island
that you need infrastructure, you know,
you're not gonna just go out there
by yourself.
Yeah.
Wow.
You're gonna need the right
people and the right pieces.
But that's something that I've been thinking
about that I'd like to try to at least do that.
That's pretty cool.
Well, it's just the there.
It's something there to be done.
That'll be, I have a feeling it'll be something special
when that happens.
Yeah. It's epic man.
All right, thank you, man.
That was great.
Laird Hamilton Surf.
That's where you're at at all of the socials, right?
Laird Superfood,
Talk to the smart people.
Yeah, are you guys in whole foods?
Yeah.
You are right?
Nationwide?
Yep.
That stuff.
Yeah, world.
That's good.
I appreciate that it's all plant-based.
Yeah.
That's good stuff.
Non-GMO.
Yeah.
Just the purest, right?
Simple well, you got to love it when you just see only
Coffee creamers.
four or five ingredients,
you gotta love that.
I've got a beautiful,
Got a beautiful
Super protein right now.
protein powder.
Yeah.
We've a protein powder.
Yeah, yeah, I'm enjoying it.
Okay, good.
And you guys sent me a bunch of stuff.
Okay, perfect.
Yeah.
That is see, I don't know anything.
I'm like I'm on the,
Yeah, I know (laughs).
No, no, you're on a need to know basis.
Yeah, I'm on a need to know basis, exactly.
(both laughing) Yeah, they don't wanna do,
Hey Laird, we need you to go ring the bell.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Get in here and ring the bell (Rich laughing).
And they call me, listen they, unlike the, I do well
like in disaster type stuff, like call it the flood
call them in, the fire, call the fire, you know,
they call me in for the, you know, the big stuff.
Right, otherwise you'll be found off-shore.
Of whatever I've been preparing to be able to be ready
Yeah (laughing).
so that when I get
called in, I can do it.
There's always that, you know,
it's like the fire department, you know, it's gonna happen
but you just gotta,
Right.
you gotta train all the time with the idea
that this is not happening right now
but it could any second,
Yeah.
maybe tomorrow, next week or next year.
Cool. All right, man.
Thank you.
All right Rich.
Come back
and talk to me again sometime.
I look forward to it.
Peace.